[Music]
hello you fabulous fun bags welcome back
to another episode of trash taste
podcast oh my god um fan fun bag number
one with [ __ ] bag number two you're
feeling fun today i'm feeling super fun
today i gotta say you you kind of look
like [ __ ] rocky balboa like about to
like run up those steps right now
there's a very sports-like jumper is it
it does look like a
like the stereotypical i'm about to i
walked in the office and called me a
[ __ ] boy
and i i don't know if i appreciated that
because you have a short hand
it's the short hair beanie in the ring i
don't know yeah you shaved your facial
hair yeah we all did yeah we all did for
the charity stream that we just finished
we're gonna be like oh my god this
episode so they recorded this so long
ago yeah yeah
we're really really dating ourselves
yeah we just recorded the charity stream
yeah which was for you guys was like a
month ago yeah yeah for us it was two
days ago it's a month and a half ago
right yeah more than that yeah yeah
we're trying to yeah we're trying to get
ahead before we fly off once again
but uh yeah if you guys didn't know
about it we just finished a 24-hour
charity stream for doctors without
borders and it was extremely successful
yeah i was very surprised we raised a
hundred and seventy six but we haven't
added the amount of 180 i think about
180 adding everything that we collected
in total
which is absolutely [ __ ] nuts i'd
like i don't know what we expected out
of this charity stream i was i was there
was a part of me when we were deciding
okay what are we gonna make our goal and
someone was like hundred thousand i was
like
in 24 that's a lot of money yeah yeah
yeah like maybe if we were like doing a
week-long subathon yeah or something
like that because i don't know i i only
did one charity stream once like years
and years ago with archie and like we
did not raise nearly that much money so
i think in the back of my head i had
that as my benchmark yeah so when i
heard a hundred thousand i was like dude
we're not [ __ ] pewdiepie or like
jacksepticeye
we're not gonna hit those numbers right
turns out we kind of did because we were
we were like number one on twitch for
like that night
yeah yeah
i think we peaked at 53 000 viewers
which is insane um yeah personal best
person
that's definitely the most i've i've
been able to it's definitely the most
i've had definitely by far well i'm not
even the streamer so that's
so that's definitely the most i've been
a part of it's just ridiculous but uh
how was the experience for you boys how
oh you know what even though i went into
it with like zero sleep it was probably
the most fun stream i've ever played
yeah yeah
i would absolutely do that again
part of me is just like i would
absolutely do that again in part not
anytime soon yeah part of me is just
like man i remember those last six hours
that was yeah i'll do it again once i
forget about how hard the last yeah i'm
like yeah this is fine
i mean at least
at least i had you guys and like chris
and like mouse there because like if i
had done it by myself i would not have
lasted like 10 hours no like i i was i
remember the last two three hours i was
just running on complete autopilot you
know when you're just using like the
part of your brain that isn't even
thinking it's just like habits you've
built up that was just me i was just
like i saw bits and pieces of the board
where you're just like you alone on the
couch and just like
thank you for the 20 donation
it kind of got to a point where i was
just like questioning my own insanity
like like because it was just sanity
sanity yeah
it's crushing my own sanity questioning
my own sanity my favorite clip though is
where you like you guys where you two
were on the couch and you just started
going lords oh all the boys
have all the boys and they got in the
most unenthusiastic way goes get hyped
guys
[Music]
it's like the most not hype get hyped
guys i've ever heard it just it just had
such like house party vibes just like
when you stay up too late and that
there's one that one guy that just
wouldn't leave yeah yeah that was that
was like that was exactly what it felt
like where i'm just like i i need to go
to bed is that one guy who doesn't know
yeah you are
you are like at every [ __ ] like all
night karaoke god is the last guy i mean
i mean i was the last guy in the stream
as well i'm just like you guys you boys
uh i mean not this wasn't the
competition obviously obviously but i i
was the only one to stay awake
right if it was conor that was in your
position he would have been like weak
you're all weak i won that competition
it was me
i carried
i think i think cause uh because i knew
you guys were there and i was like so i
can sleep and i was like yes i will yeah
but i think if it was just me alone i
would have had to i mean i would have
just oh yeah
of course and just been more miserable
yeah i mean i mean like the reason i
didn't sleep was because i knew as soon
as i closed my eyes they were not like
going
i could not go to sleep and come back up
to like stream again you know that
wouldn't stop yawning
i just i just felt horrible like i i
remember the last 30 minutes when i came
back i looked half dead yeah and i was
like oh good oh god
i think i used all my energy holding in
the laughs
yeah i like that same i use so much
energy not saying anything during like
to try not to laugh segments yeah uh
that took a lot more energy than i
thought it did it actually took more
energy than uh doing the quiz talking or
just like hanging out also not to
mention that i think we like greatly
overestimated how much energy we were
going to have because uh we had like a
schedule like a preemptive schedule that
staff made and we probably did maybe 40
of what was originally scheduled yeah i
mean it was it was it was a it was a few
things because obviously chris was
scheduled for two hours yeah stayed for
six hours which i'm i'm not i'm not
complaining i'm not complaining he was
obviously having fun yeah uh but then we
also had like a bunch of a bunch of
things that we were meant to be doing
with iron mouse but by the time chris
left and mouse came on it was just we
were so out of energy that was like we
can only manage talking right now yeah
definitely how uh how did you guys
manage to recover afterwards did you
recover easily i mean recover is a
strong word i i went home and like
weirdly enough i think because i was
kind of like
reliving the moment when i was on the
train ride home so by the time i got
home i was like wide awake for some
reason and then i i was doing a little
bit of work and then my body was just
like i don't think so
and i just [ __ ] i literally passed out
on my desk oh my god for like an hour
okay i need to go to bed
and then i slept for like 14 hours i
think oh my god and then i just
completely [ __ ] my sleep schedule for
the next day yeah i don't know like from
like my body's so weird after an
all-nighter i hate her i absolutely
[ __ ] hate it because like um during
the stream i'm like i'm gonna i'm going
to pass out as as it's well documented
that uh how close we were to passing out
yeah and uh so i remember
uh the stream finishes i do not even
remember saying like goodbye to anyone
in the office even though i know we were
just like hey congratulations
see you on see you on tuesday see you in
like two days or whatever i i think i
said see you on tuesday but i think i
just left as well i don't know if i've
seen like i was rude or something i just
i need to go to my root cause yeah and
remember like i remember like going to
my bed being like finally i've stayed up
all night for this didn't nap didn't
sleep i'm going to finally go to sleep
go on my bed and my body's just like
nope you don't you don't sleep now you
stay you stay awake you don't you don't
need sleep it is sunshine
did you stay awake
i still i stayed up for like an extra
like
it took me three hours to get to a point
where i could sleep and then i slept for
3 p.m 4 p.m yeah yeah
my day was like just [ __ ] when did you
go to bed bed then um like two in the
morning oh my god but then i did sleep
for like 16 hours so that's right so you
work at like 4 p.m the next day yeah oh
my god go on that's why like i i woke up
when i i woke up to like connor stream
jump king i was just like [ __ ]
how are these boys like awake and
streaming right now i'm like fighting
for my life sunday i went home and then
i had like three hours sleep and then i
went out for some drinks and a meal how
the [ __ ] i was like fine how how
i got tired around
10 p.m so i went home and uh then i
slept woke up early and played jump king
but i finished it you finished it yeah
right you both finished it right i
finally finished babe with the ascension
yeah it's just like the worst thing ever
i don't even want to do it ever again
finally finished the base game that was
uh when are you gonna do the dlc joy
you know you know what sucks like at the
end of that stream i was like you can't
pay me to play the dlc i want my
happiness back in my life but then the
moment i turned off the stream i was
like [ __ ] i can't want to keep playing
yeah because you're like you're like but
there's more yeah because because it was
it was the fact that there was so much
encouragement online when i posted my
time and people were like dude you're
actually cracked and i was like
okay give give me a little more prank
the game has a way of humbling you
because i thought the same thing when i
did like the third dlc i was like i'm
correct dude i'll be able to do this new
one like yeah yeah i was like i was
actually like worried i was like what if
i like beat this drc too fast too fast
and it's like not a good stream yeah
yeah and then like the first eight hours
of playing it i was like oh no
oh no this is hard this is really hard
and it took me 48 hours
to beat the dlc the fan made dlc but now
i know what it feels like to be an alpha
gamer yeah and now i can finally say hey
god when are you finishing
jumping i will i'll do it again i
[ __ ] feel like you know [ __ ] that
scene in [ __ ] my hero academia where
like all my is just pointing at you so
it's your turn
i'm just here watching on tv i'm not
even like involved and here you are
pointing at me being like it's your turn
you've done half of it so you have to do
the other thing it's a half of it is it
half of it uh gone gone to maybe like 40
yeah i got it where did you
like before that the the the town in the
sky
bargain that's it
i mean i will finish here just because i
i knew it's like one thing when i
started it and i was just like it's i i
have the same inkling feeling in me
where i just doesn't it doesn't feel
comfortable until i'm i finish it take
your time
yeah yeah it's been a few weeks since
your last we're gonna get rusty you're
stuck with zero again i'll be fine i'll
be fine it'll be uh i will be like pure
muscle yeah it'd be it'd be like you
never left it's gonna be like dementia
the game with guys every time he goes
back to he's like oh i gotta learn this
section again
it'll be like 30 if uh like my
playthrough would be like 50 hours or
something spread because
if anything you now have someone else to
compare yourself to and that's may lean
because she also started it as well oh
my god and uh that stream last night was
hilarious
started it as well yeah
jesus christ yeah it's like a virus but
don't worry if you if you thought look
like meleen just got to the bottom of
the sewers and it took her like a couple
of hours to get there so i just think
it's like the one of the best games to
stream it's just so it's so intuitive
there's no explanation needed yeah you
know like some games it's like power ups
level ups you know and then there's like
oh you can unlock this thing and then
everyone's like oh what's going on but
jump king is literally just
you can one mechanic jump one box you
understand immediately from watching
that they're trying to go up and when
they fall you're like oh i get it this
is fun to watch it's also just a pretty
game it's good it's a really pretty game
yeah i love the aesthetic yeah i i will
say you know i thought you were
bullshitting when
you said oh it's you know it's a fun
game it's a fun game but no it is i do
actually genuinely think it's a fun game
there's a high that you get when you've
reached like your new personal best yeah
you know what i mean you're like damn
you're like this is a good feeling and
then that lasts for like three seconds
before you like fall for the first time
i know we spoke about jumping so much on
this podcast now it's just like taking
over my life but uh on the first map
there's like a very solid checkpoint
when you get to that you feel like i can
do this the 70 percent one right yeah
yeah when you get to the the church the
church yeah and then you're like oh my
god i can do this yeah that's when it
feels good yeah that's when i was like
all right i got this you got this king
yeah yeah you can do it then if you can
get that you can do it easily so dlc for
me is a hard maybe then you should do it
i think i think i want to like maybe
put in a couple of like other games that
i've been wanting to play hard maybe
what does that even mean
joe are you like being like joey won't
ever commit to anything no maybe he's
about the best you can get yeah
i mean you know it's better than arcane
yeah we'll fly outside
maybe
maybe
maybe is like i i am committed to my
neutrality here yeah it could be yes it
could
be the bride
maybe
that's a hard movie
was your viewership higher than normal
when you were doing jump king oh yeah
yeah for sure for sure but you know it's
like what do i what do i prioritize
clout or happiness
it's a hard choice for every youtuber
you can have both
i'm just waiting for when the kirby game
comes out dude that's when that's real
happy i play games now like when i'm
playing like when i play pokemon r6 i'm
like there's just not enough
challenge even though there was there
literally was like there definitely was
but the thing was that i never once
thought for a moment i wasn't going to
be able to do it whereas jump king has
that thing where it's like i don't know
if you can do it man wait but you did
the you did that last fight
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you struggled a
lot with it i did but like at no point
did i ever feel like this is too hard
really yeah because like to me like that
was easily the hardest in-game pokemon
fight it is it is even then i like
there's no point where doing it where
i'm like i don't know if i can do this
yeah i don't think like i just felt like
i just got to grind a little bit more i
don't know man
was hard as [ __ ] okay yeah yeah i want
to see you where's like new babe plus
when i was playing that game with jump
king's the second map yeah that was like
i i did it over three streams so one on
stream second stream third stream
the the second stream after it and i
went to bed yeah i had like anxiety i
was like i was like what if i just like
can't do it
what if i can't do it yeah like i'm
never gonna be able to forget this if i
can't do it
and then i woke up next stage bossed it
just destroyed it right right wow damn i
think you have an addiction i do yeah
there's definitely an addiction because
you know
there's been like uh i kind of got out
of like um multiplayer games that was
kind of where i got the kick from
beating other people but yeah you know
there's a hard ceiling in multiplayer
games where you're like if i want to be
able to improve at this game i have to
put an absurd amount of hours in right
yeah consistently yeah wait but is is 45
hours in one jump king map not a
[Music]
an fps first person shooter multiplayer
game whatever yeah 45 hours is nothing
that's true that's absolutely nothing
you're competing against people who do
45 hours a week yeah how many hours have
you put us into all of jump king right
now uh 100 something that's that's
that's quite a lot yeah that's the
persona yeah that's a percentage
throughout the apex i have like over a
thousand probably yeah that's true like
it's and even then like i'm i'm just
like uh i got to master once and that
was that was like that was me going
insane right well why don't you get into
more like challenging games then because
you you said you don't really play like
the souls types games or like i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna do algebra but like
i feel like that's it's a different type
of challenge because we're jumping it's
just like one mechanic that you have to
like milestone and master whereas with
something like elden ring or sifu it's
like a lot of things going on at once
you know there's a lot of different
approaches a lot of ways to master the
game yeah yeah i just like jumping
because there's no like there's no
[ __ ] there's like if you [ __ ] up
absolutely nothing there's no other
facts single factor yeah because with
games like dark souls or like seafood
yeah it's like it's like you can blame
it on like the enemy like [ __ ] that one
frame hit me yeah yeah yeah yeah i i
know i'll make up exactly
there's no enemies to get in your way
it's just it's just you you're in the
way of yourself you are your own enemy
yeah yeah exactly almost like [ __ ] no
no don't trust anyone not even yourself
i mean like the each dlc gets more
brutal though like on you know the first
jumping you can only fall like two
screens max that's what i'm dreading man
and i felt like 20. what if i like
actually start raging
i do
but i don't i don't want that though i
don't want to get angry not like an
actual angry though like a like an angry
video game angry
it's a different kind of anger i don't
know how to explain it it's an anger
where you're like
you shout but it doesn't actually like
actually get you upset right kind of
like ah
all right back to you
this is it's just like a slight
frustration slight annoyance
it's stubbing your toe
well no there's there's there's
different
kinds of video games i don't know what
that analogy is yeah but i i i'm not
angry when i start myself yeah like not
like
like not like a 13 year old on xbox live
anger where i just test out all the new
bad words i've learned right yeah
like you know like a
mild frustration like when the website
when you fill out the whole form and
then it reloads for some reason you're
like
oh yeah yeah and then you like really
that's that's the anger you feel dude
when when you should have have you not
had that i get so angry when that
happens that's like you've like filled
out a whole sign up form put the credit
card info in the address in all the
right space you're about to go to the
checkout for some reason time's out for
somebody it times out or it reloads
you're like
like [ __ ] guts theme goes through my
head yeah is it even worth signing up
again i don't know i don't know if this
is worth it anymore i don't even want
the trampoline yeah
the worst part is when you fill out
everything correctly except for that one
field but the website's assigned in a
way that when you press send it it goes
uh this one field is incorrect we've
reset the whole but they reset the
entire [ __ ] that's except for that
one field like imagine that happens but
just it happens to every website you
sign up that's that's like there's so
many japanese websites every japanese
website dude like i don't know if
japanese people are aware of ux
designers yeah they certainly it's just
like the amount of times i've been like
[ __ ] cucked by not using like half
width yeah
this is the my [ __ ] god
this is the biggest joke in japan and
like it's something you'll never
experience unless you've either tried to
buy stuff in like on the japanese
website but for some reason they have
full width and hearth with katakana and
can you explain that by the way what is
the point of full width and half i'll
tell you exactly the difference okay
there is none that's what's so
frustrating about it someone explained
it to me one time i had something to do
with how they coded way back the initial
internet oh yeah in japan and it was
like a layover from that essentially
that they're probably using yeah they
never like decided to sort out yeah i
mean like i've told the story of how i
interned for an it company and i had to
fix a bunch of like clients websites and
i had to go like through the html and i
had like almost had a stroke looking at
some of these codes because it's like oh
my god you said you built this website
last year you're using code literally
from the 90s
i was like what of course this like of
course this page takes like 20 seconds
to load even though it's just text based
because it's so much [ __ ] code here
because [ __ ] uh it's so weird because
there's so much like convenience stuff
and stuff crazy stuff you can do that
you can't do in other countries yeah and
then they're like how about websites we
just you just keep them [ __ ] you just
keep weirdly enough the best designed
websites are the [ __ ] anime trailer
websites
right yeah the ones that are like they
use like [ __ ] like pretty like java
and like css it's like oh that looks
fantastic yeah like when that website
was like when the last bucket like when
a guitar you uh volume was coming out
yeah just like scrolling down for the
entire history yeah of uh of the series
i was like damn this is a beautiful
looking website oh my god someone an
actual coder yeah and that's the
programmer made this dude like can you
not add this to your ui design when i'm
trying to [ __ ] buy something exactly
sign up to a site like rockton is just
like a hell hole of a website because
you don't know you go to like because
like on amazon for example amazon's so
good yeah because on amazon it's like
okay there's the [ __ ] picture of the
thing you want to buy there's how many
is left when it's gonna arrive here's
all the information everything is
perfectly laid out with every single
item yeah meanwhile with roktan it's
just a [ __ ] free-fall it's like would
you like 17 banners that have nothing to
do with the product you're actually
buying by the way where is the purchase
button oh it's buried deep beneath this
[ __ ] wall of text and every time i go
on a rocket it's so handy because you
get so much stuff on rockton that you
can't get on amazon yeah but it's a
[ __ ] it's just a struggle to try and
like buy anything because it doesn't
even tell you when it arrives i don't
know that's that's not the final boss
the final boss is yahoo
oh my god where you you can't even like
immediately you can't even sign up with
an account that you want you need like a
special you need a special yahoo account
yeah uh so you need to just sign up to
yahoo and it just it's not your normal
yahoo it's japanese yahoo as well i have
a yahoo email account something like
duncan or something i don't know if they
chose the name for me yeah it's really
weird
of course it's a yahoo japan account
because no one outside of japan you just
[ __ ] right exactly so you need to
sign up with a special yahoo account to
sign up to this uh yahoo auctions
account to then
just not even like
i don't even know what the etiquette is
in terms of like bidding stuff and how
to do it
yahoo auctions just because i refuse to
make a yahoo because i i i i have a bad
rating on it because i forgot one time
to say i got the thing oh yeah yeah
i got that on miraculous
angry message from a dude who was like
why haven't you told me that you got it
this has been an awful experience for me
i'm like
uh
i just figured if i didn't say anything
that means like i got it yeah yeah right
you'd think so but like how did you how
did you pay can you pay with like credit
card or something yeah so it's really
confusing because there's like when you
auto-translate it in google there's like
online pay and like something else that
sounds like online pay yeah yeah and i
remember that i was confused and i
clicked one of them and then i had
through this whole weird kind of thing
with my bank where i had to then like
contact my bank to do the online payment
oh my god where there was just another
field that just let you put your credit
card information in and it isn't clear
it wasn't it didn't say like credit card
it said something else yeah really
annoying really really annoying i hate
using it
don't bother that's what i mean like as
well a lot of the websites that offer
english
they're like okay you click english send
it to a brand new website that doesn't
have half the [ __ ] the jam yeah yeah
yeah whereas like amazon it's like you
changed english nothing changes except
the language yeah it's like great it's
exactly like you know when you when you
go to like a chinese restaurant with
your one chinese mate and they're like
yeah bring out the special thank you
bring out the real me i don't know why
it's like chinese restaurants in
particular but it seems like every
chinese restaurant has the special menu
that you can only that you can only get
by asking in cantonese or manchester
united or whatever and i bet they're not
even saying like bring out the real
minions probably just like a code word
you know
it's like
mandarin is an orange and they're like i
said the word all right bring it out
right now i just like it just it just
blows my mind because like you know i go
to a thai restaurant and i can ask them
in thai whether they have you know a you
know a thai dish that's
like they only like do in thailand or
only time most pi thai people would know
but like it's just like why is it that
chinese restaurant just have an unspoken
understanding that there's going to be
so many people asking for a special menu
that they're going to make a special
menu in every single choice why are they
literally gatekeeping
literally
like if you're not chinese you can't get
the real [ __ ] you know
it makes me feel sad though because i
love chinese food but i know right i
never want to go to a chinese restaurant
without a chinese i know i know right it
sucks because it feels like you've just
unlocked the starter the starter kit
right and you need to learn mandarin to
get to get like the actual good gear
right
do you know what i mean because like i
love chinese food but the best chinese
food i've had has not come from the
normal menu no like if i go to like a
chinese restaurant and i see like
[ __ ] you know orange chicken sweet
and sour chicken fried rice all this
stuff i was like this no no give me the
real [ __ ] yeah give me please give give
me the real [ __ ] but i i don't know how
to access it like where is your chinese
friend
i do not know i don't see him
you just just just speak chinese right
just just speak mandarin
could you imagine if like mcdonald's did
that it's like oh where's your american
friend wait well i know shake shack does
though does it do they yeah they were
secret they have secret items really
yeah i didn't know that you didn't know
this
no no shake shack sorry uh uh i don't
know internet oh in and out i got it in
an hour
special menu
you can get like the
you can
well i don't know it's like animal style
fries that's a secret menu oh yeah yeah
i know that yeah and then there's like a
is that a secret menu that i feel that's
like so well known now but if you're
like uh if you're a tourist from asia
don't speak english oh that's true
you're like and you're like what what's
that guy called the phone
number
i know you can get a flavor where like
they mix all the
uh
um or the milkshake flavors into one oh
which sounds sounds interesting yeah if
you want that
i think there's something else there's
another secret burger or something as
well i know there are secret items at
fast food chains secret items items why
would they have not
yeah i don't know that because because
they don't because the pain in the ass
to make but is it a marketing thing you
reckon also that as well yeah yeah it
makes you seem like you're you're like
in this part of the secret society yeah
i i got the real stuff give me the real
stuff you've been to those like uh
places that are like secret uh bars or
clubs or anything oh like they invite
only ones yeah yeah
yeah i one of my friends took me to one
where it was literally it's in tokyo i'm
obviously not going to say where but
like it literally just
i don't know
i've been i've been there it literally
looks like a
concrete wall
and he just like
i was with my friend and he's like okay
we're here and i'm like what do you mean
where is this
it's like ah it's in roppongi somewhere
i think we went to one in shibuya right
yeah that's easy they said like closed
and it was like closed due to corona oh
the door and they just yeah so it was it
was literally it wasn't he wasn't even
just look it looked close it was just
scaffolding and like and like oh
like this place was like being built
yeah
and you just knock on the door and like
um like an actual speakeasy like the
[ __ ] yeah
opens up yeah my my one had that as well
so like he knocked like he he's like oh
i have to knock a specific way as well
i'm like [ __ ] you do and he did like
a secret like pattern and then the thing
came up and he was like password or one
and then he said the password and he's
like
friend
he pointed at me and he's like yeah a
friend i was like
okay
and then he opens it up and it's just
this tiny like maybe three person bar
right and uh
it was all right i guess it was all
right it was cool that i was in the
coolest part it was just going to uh
what looked like a secret bar the
coolest part was just like the dude
opening up like this i'm like i've only
ever seen that movie i went to one where
it was in london um i went to it and it
was like a
like a
breakfast restaurant or something
on the top yeah we went in there and i
didn't know the password and neither did
my friend and then we were like
we don't know what the password is yeah
he was like
it's a daft punk song lyric
and then it was like he's like giving
clothes he was like feeling it to me and
i was like it was something like uh i'm
up all night to get lucky or something
right
okay so he said it and then he was like
it's not even like an obscure darth park
song you just go through their entire
disciples
i was like which which album
were we talking about okay okay can't be
too many lyrics yeah if it's dark funk
lyrics that that that narrows is it
around the world
so then um
we're here and then some guy comes and
greets us and we start walking through
this uh restaurant that's closed
and then like in a movie we go in the
kitchen and there's people like working
in the kitchen and we're just like
walking through oh [ __ ]
and we go down into a basement in the
kitchen and there's like boxes of fries
and [ __ ] all around us
yeah and then like like like in like in
a [ __ ] spy movie it's got the [ __ ]
beads
oh [ __ ] that opens it up that's this
room it means it's funny
but there's like no uh real like chairs
or anything it's kind of like a
a very small room that's very dimly lit
and it didn't it wasn't that good the
drinks are okay yeah and i was like this
is the coolest part was walking to this
thing oh yeah yeah yeah i want to leave
yeah what i've always wanted to know
what why would you opt to make a
business like that right like you you i
feel like yeah i feel clearly like if
you're going to opt to be like okay i'm
going to make this so exclusive that
it's like near impossible for a regular
person to find then it's like you're
clearly not doing it
as a sustainable business you know
you're clearly doing it as like a
[ __ ] horse i mean it's the assumption
is you'll be able to survive on word of
mouth i guess that's that's the hope a
lot of people like it's so cool you
gotta go yeah and then yeah the drinks
are very mediocre yeah the experience
feels worth it because you feel
exclusive yeah i mean just bragging
rights right yeah you pay for the
experience and not so much the you know
the bar or the business or the uh drinks
itself it's like it's like bars that are
membership only right and you can only
get membership by having someone
recommend you like that that always
seemed really silly to me but there's so
many of them well that's like that's
like like half of like the golden guy
yeah membership half of nichole as well
as like that as well yeah it's like if
you don't know someone who either works
there or goes there frequently enough
they just won't let you in yeah yeah but
at the same time like i i can get it
with the bars and golden guy because the
bars are so small that i'm sure that
their regular customers can keep them
keep their business up and running yeah
anyway you just need like one or two
patrons so you keep get yourself going
and then you're basically set that's
true that's true they're basically set
it'd be pretty cool to own a like tiny
little bar in golden gai i've always
thought about that but it's like what
but like it's like to get a bar yeah
that's what i've always wanted i'm like
you're but like
all those bars even though they're so
tiny i'm sure they're paying out the ass
to have that space which made a trash
taste bar there i've trashed asparagus
taste special build a bar build a bar in
golden gate all three of us build our
own bars and golden guy see who makes
the most money at the end of the night
i don't even want to do
i don't even want to think about how
much it must cost to like rent out a
space i'd get really claustrophobic
walking uh working on one of those
it's cozy i think it's cozy yeah i think
it's cozy
it depends i've been in i've been in
somewhere it's like i i literally can't
stand up straight yeah inside of them
right now it's literally a shoebox yeah
it is yeah um and i don't even know how
they get into the bar let alone
work well most of them are like you know
four feet tall like all barchans right
exactly they probably don't have any
problems it's not built for someone of
my stature like if i stand up i
literally my my like head literally hits
the ceiling like i feel like gandalf in
frodo's house in a lot of these places
i'm just constantly like can i get a
drink please
normally if you're wide that's the
problem though no not if you're tall
yeah yeah that's true but that's why
like going in the winter time is the
worst because you're like all puffed up
with jackets and [ __ ] just like all
right out of the way please sorry excuse
me
i think it's best to get a winter in the
summer if it's weird i don't know why i
feel in the summer it's just way too hot
it's really hot yeah even though the ac
is going it's still though either way
it's it's very much a gamble
i've i've heard so many horror stories
in golden gai and like nichole me and
all that kind of stuff don't go into a
bar if someone tells you to go into a
bar that's the rule of thumb yeah yeah
if somebody's trying to tell you to go
into their bar that's probably a good
sign to not go into this probably a bad
idea gentlemen this episode of trash
taste is sponsored by expressvpn going
online without expressvpn is like using
your smartphone without a case it's
barbaric most of the time you'll be fine
but all it takes is one incident for you
to wish that you used a case every time
you connect to an unencrypted network in
cafes hotels airports etc your online
data is not secured any hacker on the
network can gain access and steal your
personal data passwords financial
details and more it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone just
some cheap hardware so why use
expressvpn well it creates a secure and
encrypted tunnel between you and the
internet so hackers won't be able to
find out what you're doing and it's
super secure it would take a hacker over
a billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption and me and the boys have been
using expressvpn for a god damn hot
minute and yeah it's just so easy it's
so easy you just click the button and it
works so secure your online data today
by going to expressvpn.com
taste that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trash taste and you get an extra three
months free expressvpn.com
trash taste link in the description back
to the episode um yeah i've only been
into like golden guy like two times i
haven't been that many times um and it's
been a interesting experience every time
yeah
the last time i went was with you guys
and at that bar that was fun yeah which
was really really fun that's a good time
yeah we're like
uh that's the one that uh jan came to oh
that one and he immediately went behind
the bar and started well he just
basically just took over the box took
over yeah it was because the woman who
was at the bar got tired or something
yeah it was like this it was owned by
this like what looked like at least 70
80 year old like old lady she was really
really nice but she was like clearly
standing at the bar all night and the
moment jan came in she was like oh that
looks like a charismatic enough guy to
take over my bath for the night
and so she literally she literally
ushers jan over because there were no
seats left because yeah there was like
us three and like two other japanese
people and that that was it it was so
small so jan comes in he's like i got
nowhere to sit old lady just like ushers
jano and he's like take over and this
just goes behind the back and we never
see her for the rest of the night and
i'm just like uh we can just like we can
just leave if we wanted to obviously we
paid at the end of it it's like a
thousand yen a drink but like it was
like you were pouring the drinks so it
was like yeah you could just make it as
strong as you wanted exactly strange
it became a self-service bar
i don't know how jan has this effect
like basically everywhere he goes where
he just sweet talks
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] restaurant the waiter or the
bar lady to give us the special service
or the special menu the menu that
doesn't exist yeah yeah yeah
it's always it's always something like
johnny was able to get jan is the only
man that can somehow pull out a secret
menu from a restaurant that doesn't even
have a secret menu yeah he's just like
oh i guess we have a secret menu now
[ __ ] i bring it up this guy
imagine like going to like a british
restaurant or something and like gotta
get out the secret menu and it's just
like toast sandwich
unfortunately it's a crisp toast
sandwich crisp sandwich for sure that i
think the uk is the one place for sweet
talking doesn't do anything yeah you
just like no really no i've never seen
anyone sweet talk anything in the uk
maybe in a bar with one guy yeah like in
a restaurant it will never work or maybe
it's because they just don't have like
secret menu culture maybe no we don't
yeah
what would be on like the japanese
secret menu there was like uh if you
want to if you went to like an abroad
japanese
or something yeah i don't know i feel
like we don't have secret menus here
either just because like we don't even
have tipping culture here because we're
so like just so like these are the rules
we can't make any kind of exceptions
would you want to hide something if
you're proud of it right
well like like what i'm talking about is
if you go to a japanese restaurant not
in japan oh i said what would be like
the foods on there that would be
something that you a japanese person
very accustomed to japanese cuisine
would know but not is like i guess not
mainstream enough to be on like to be so
you're asking what the most underrated
japanese food is
like or like unknown
i would say you'd probably be something
slimy like most of the [ __ ] that we
ended up feeling in the uh what's in the
box and the charities like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like [ __ ] like
that
yeah yeah probably something like that
like maybe like i don't know um
natto on in curry maybe because i feel
like a lot of izakaya foods would be on
there oh yeah definitely like
yeah like uh like the blended squid and
stuff like that or like takawasa that
[ __ ]
oh that's just ball oh no way no way hey
man you're you're part of my team now
because you're like natto okay natto
natto was actually right it was it was
all right the taste is fine but the
slime is just dreadful yeah really vile
the slime is it's not even the worst
texture i've had in japan i feel like it
looks a lot worse than it tastes and
feels in your mouth i think
like uh i think the beans taste pretty
good i mean it just tastes
like soy sauce i think i mean it smells
very basically what it is i mean that's
what it is soy sauce on soy beans yeah
yeah soy overload right right i mean i
feel though if because you guys ate it
like straight out of the packet you got
like the full brunt of like the the
sliminess and the texture but like when
you put that on a bed of rice because
you're eating it with rice it doesn't
feel as slimy yeah i feel like i'm sure
like with a bit of rice it would be
perfect yeah it would be absolutely
fantastic yeah i mean i i guess you know
you gotta you gotta give it a go give it
a go give it a go if you don't like it
it's totally fine maybe maybe you'll
like it maybe you're not yeah like i did
to me like i i learned that uh i just
can't handle ketchup i i don't know why
i don't know why like that was the plus
that was that was a lot of kids that was
the first time like so what
we all had forfeits to do i had to eat
pizza crust drenched in ketchup and
mayonnaise because i hate ketchup and
mayonnaise and i don't need the crust
and then i don't need to crust and i
remember like i was like i'm gonna give
this the best go that i possibly can
because this is for charity and it's the
first time where
i've put something in my mouth and i had
like immediate gag reflux that's your
mind
like to me like the natto like i was
just like maybe i'm going to gag during
the nasa and i had it and i'm just like
because you expected to gag i think you
expected to like throw up so you're
you're psyching yourself out the moment
you it touched your tongue you're like
yeah um to be fair that
smells pretty dreadful but i had to do
the ghost pepper that was uh that was
how was that experience
that that hurt see because like you know
you guys were saying like oh you know
and everyone in the chat was saying oh
look forward to the next morning like
you're gonna you're gonna be [ __ ]
through a straw and i was like oh god no
no the ramen was way worse yeah the
ramen was way worse than we had but um
yeah i was fine like i had maybe like
one painful [ __ ] and then i thought that
was going to be like the the beginning
of the end no no no no
no the one that spicy is the yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah i was fine after that
i just you know i look back on the this
clip of me like shivering for 15 minutes
afterwards and i'm like i literally look
like i'm about to [ __ ] die
yeah i was like getting slightly worried
when you start shivering yeah i know
it's because your body is just going
into shock yeah pretty much and uh you
you're like your body is rushing you
with like [ __ ] adrenaline and
endorphins and all that kind of [ __ ] and
i just remember seeing you like go like
this and i'm just like so you are you
are right man
and like you know i think the worst part
about it is when you watch that out of
context you see a dude who looks clearly
sleep-deprived with like huge bags under
his eyes shivering i just look like a
crack addict
like i just look like i was having
withdrawals i was like sleepy like
[Music]
it was not the best look i don't think
the sleep deprivation helped as well
because i can't imagine trying like
trying a food that you really it's seven
in the morning yeah it was seven in the
morning we were up for like 20 hours at
that point and you're like
perfect time perfect time to eat a
ghostbuster no
to be honest i couldn't taste anything
oh yeah there was no flavor was it as
painful as you thought it would be i
yeah i i find that like sauce
sauces like really like heavy
sauce-based dishes that are spicy are
the hardest to eat because like you know
like the hot ones stuff yeah i can eat
all of those hot one sauce like the
hottest ones on wings like no issue like
i don't need milk or anything like that
it's just it tastes good like the last
dab i like i like slather everything in
that right and it's all it's all good
because it's just a few bites but it's
very solid
but like we did the ramen video for
yours yeah and that wasn't that spicy
like it it i'd say like it's not as
spicy as like a
ghost pepper or a carolina reaper yeah
because it's just sauce yeah it coats
your mouth
coats your like esophagus and then it
goes into your stomach and it it hurts
so much yeah and then it takes a while
so you just keep eating yeah eating i
definitely struggle more i think with
that than the ghost pebble one burst of
spice is not that bad it's when you keep
eating bursts of spice yeah yeah like
that
multiplies yeah you don't you don't give
yourself a break that's why like eating
one carolina reaper for me it's like
totally chill like i could do it now and
we could still film the episode and it'd
be chill yeah
eating like those competitions where
they get like 40. i'm like that's fine
how has anyone not died from that that's
[ __ ] i don't know because
i don't think you can die from spice no
you can go into shock though you can go
into shock but i don't has there been a
recorded spa uh recorded case of someone
dying from spice i'm not sure
if there is there has been you can burn
a hole through your stomach
i don't necessarily think that's true
though i think yeah you'd have to have a
pretty weak stomach though i feel yeah
because like it's a factor of things
cause like for me as someone who like
loves spicy food like trying to explain
why i eat spicy food or why like you
know like joey's jerry's said to me all
the time like i don't know how you can
like get through that or something like
that and i think one thing that's really
under
like underrated about why people eat
spicy food is that the spicy food needs
to taste good yeah you know because we
when we think of like spicy challenges
we just think about getting through
getting through how spicy this spicy
meal is or getting through like this
[ __ ] pepper or something but a big
draw of spicy food is that if it's even
if you're in [ __ ] pain and you know
your mouth is hurting if it tastes good
with the spice
you want to finish it and you want to
eat it because it tastes good i mean
that was it with the ramen video like i
would not have finished that if it
didn't taste as good as it did yeah and
it tastes really [ __ ] good if that
did not taste good i would just been
like no [ __ ] this yeah like i felt like
for example like the koko ichiban level
10 spice and it is spicy but it doesn't
taste good at all like it just feels
like you're making it spicy to make it
spicy it's artificial it's just
artificial right sometimes it just feels
like you're this is just you know this
is just a flex at the end we can make it
this spicy but it doesn't even like the
taste doesn't marry well with the spice
at all and it just like if like proper
good spicy dishes need to taste good it
needs to complement the actual base food
right yeah yeah exactly like i have like
for example i have like thai food
without the spice and it literally does
feel like there's a there's a component
that's missing from the food
um
so good yeah are you going to say astrid
uh capsaicin
does cause uh tissue inflammation so if
so a large enough dose could cause
serious damage to your stomach i feel
you'd have to have like an egregious
amount though to hit that point uh or
something really spicy and have it all
in one sitting you could do enough
damage to potentially kill you
um i i just uh uh
my ex-girlfriend was sri lankan yeah i
remember when i went to
to meet her parents and stuff
everything had chilis in it
it was amazing yeah i loved it yeah i
was like it was like breakfast omelette
with like five of those peppers that you
put in like thai food yeah
and i and i i ate them all and then i
don't know if i told the story her mom
came in and was like
why did he eat the peppers
and i was like am i not supposed to eat
the peppers and she was like no you'll
get stomach cancer if you eat the
peppers i'm like why would you put them
in the food
what the [ __ ]
they were delicious
like it was good yeah there's also like
another restaurant because she took me
around to a bunch of the local
restaurants and there's one thing where
it's like deviled mutton it was called
or something yeah and it was like that
sounds badass it was like the most
delicious
marinated mutton i'd ever had in my life
damn but it was like like doom level of
spice or if it's got the word
yeah
that's the thing about spicy food if
it's really good spicy food you're like
you power through you pound
you're in a pain but you're just like oh
it just tastes so good though i don't
know how to explain it but like when
it's super spicy and super delicious
it's almost like it's searing in the
flavor yeah
i'm like this is so much flavor
because it's almost like if you take the
spice out because of like for example
i've had like very oh yeah you know i've
had unspiced thai curry i've had
unspiced indian curry as well
in england and uh and
the best way i can describe it is that
it just tastes flat you know it's it
tastes flat there's something that's
missing from the taste right
uncarbonated
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of
that's a good analogy actually it's it's
you the flavor's there but there's like
a texture the flavor is there but the
personality is gone exactly
engine car you know if you have rice
with it too or you have nan i feel like
that's so nice to have like spice with
it because yeah yeah yeah it kind of
helped smell of it out a bit yeah yeah
yeah yeah see because like i never for
the longest time i didn't understand
that concept of like spice enhancing
food because you know up until i'd say
maybe like three or four years ago i
could not handle spice at all like if i
went to kokuichi i would do like level
one which is like the most basic [ __ ]
and i'd just be like no too spicy i
can't do it and then i don't know what
it was that like where just one day i
kind of just flipped a dime and i was
like
you know what this it hurts but i'm
enjoying it for some reason yeah what is
what is this see i i had like the
opposite journey of joey some i've like
someone who's grown up on tafe with thai
food and stuff like that so like i would
i like i remember as a kid i like really
did not like japanese food at all
because a lot of japanese cuisine
revolves around you know the natural
flavor of savory less savoring it and
just bringing out the natural flavors of
the ingredient and me a thai person
being like
there is not enough ingredients in this
dish what sushi sushi what that's that's
just dry ingredients that's rice and
fish what where's the spice where's the
flavor
yeah three ingredients like you know
rice yeah rice with a bit of vinegar in
it yeah uh fish and wasabi i'm just like
where's the five million spices to go
with it what what you dip it in soy
sauce where's where's the chillies in
the soy sauce what's the kick yeah
where's the kick and uh like like
japanese cuisine was like my least
favorite cuisine because to me there
just wasn't weren't enough like
extra spices or extra ingredients to
enhance the flavors unseasoned sushi
and then as i grew older i'm just like
you as as a grower i learned to really
appreciate the subtleties in the flavor
of like japanese cuisine where you it
really enhances um it really enhances
like you know the good ingredients just
right it's just right it's also the same
you know
chef's training for 20 years
to get the perfect rice it's all right
it's all the same
well i [ __ ] love the golden rice in
those microwave packets though i [ __ ]
love that rice oh the they're ready to
make ones right yeah yeah tastes so good
yeah yeah they did
all the artificial [ __ ] in it yeah
exactly fast food rice how do we make
rice unhealthy super unhealthy we found
a way
yeah honestly like the fast food uh the
the packeted fried rice that you can buy
is actually pretty damn in japan it's
pretty good oh the one that you might
have yeah
yeah i was like oh well i made curry and
i don't want to make i didn't have a
rice cooker at the time yeah yeah and i
hated making rice the way that my mum
taught me which was just boil a pan full
of water yes
yeah which sometimes worked sometimes
didn't yeah
but doing it in japan is like
blasphemous i know i know i know but
it's like it's weird because you'd think
that like the first people to adapt an
easier way to do it yeah would be white
people
because they love being lazy that's true
so like you'd think they you'd think
rice cookers would go down like
especially for the uk where we love rice
yeah like we love eating it with curry
so like you'd think too do people in the
uk love rice with curry that's pretty
much it though but that's the only thing
we eat half the time
chicken tikka masala is like every every
week that's true you'd think that we
would figure out like hey these rice
cookers aren't so bad yeah because like
i remember growing up in the uk whenever
i'd like have my pack lunch or whatever
it would be like you know you'd never
make rice for a pack lunch it's the
dinner thing yeah no sorry tea tea no
[ __ ] um
longer
no but like i remember having this
conversation with my mates and they were
like wait you eat rice every day with
every meal and i'm like yeah yeah like
you you have it with every meal yeah
and they couldn't like wrap their heads
around you bougie [ __ ] yeah you
eat rice with everything everything you
don't take a brace from right right i
break from rice you just it's everything
i'm like yeah it's it's asia it's asian
cuisine you could you literally eat rice
within every with everything i'm sure
the asians are asking the same thing
being like wait we you use bread with
everything
every meal is with bread it's bread or
potatoes yeah wait is that it is that
bread of potatoes
carbs on carbs
i mean i think it's i think it's grown a
lot popularity there in the last 10
years especially rice yeah definitely
not when i was growing up but so yeah
it's become way more popular like rice
based uh dishes in general but you know
i think uh i i say finally
i'm sorry yeah yeah but i think there's
enough dishes where people are making
them where a rice cooker
you're peeled by bread makers people
aren't making bread every [ __ ] day
and if those things are [ __ ] messy
yeah right
my little rice cooker's like this big
but the point was before i did this uh i
used to just buy the microwave packets
they're amazing like 300 gram packets
yeah perfect portion tastes great
slap it on the plate you're good to go
yeah yeah i actually think i actually
you know i actually think those
i i also survived without a rice cooker
in university for a long time because
because the microwave packets were good
enough and the problem with a rice
cooker um i find is that rice goes off
so [ __ ] quick so either you like cook
a tiny bit of rice in this massive rice
cooker because i'm asian and of course
like if a mom if if a mom buys you a
rice cooker it's like the biggest
[ __ ] rice cooker you can ever imagine
how many families do you want to feed
it's like this restaurant where it's
like this
big there was luckily there was a
humanitarian crisis but it wasn't for
long because ghan had his rice burger
and his mum gave him yeah
yeah because because like my mom but my
mom like bought me a rice cooker for
university because that's like that's
like one of the essential pieces of
equipment that you need for university
for every asian kid that the mum
provides of course and they provide you
a rice cooker that could survive a
nuclear winter you know you you you you
pretty sure you can like i'm pretty sure
you like hop inside of it and survive a
blast yeah right right but the problem
is like i would always cook too much
rice or too little rice right that yeah
i would either like it would be like
either too much for the meal i was
cooking i would have some leftover rice
um or i'd have cooked too much rice and
like the rice just goes off so quickly
even if you put it in the fridge or
something uh because unless you're rea
this is this is the asian trap right
because with the rice cooker you have to
eat rice every day in order to cook in
order to eat all the rice that you
cooked with the rice cooking right
otherwise it's just gonna go off exactly
um so that's why actually the microwave
packets were just like the perfect
portion yeah for
for like one meal and it was just like a
lot less effort yeah because then you
have to like start experimenting like
you look in your fridge and be like all
right
what can the rice go with that i haven't
tried i wonder can you
dehydrate the rice that you've cooked
turn it back into a rice cream is that
possible well i mean uh if you had the
technology i'm asking is it possible
well i mean like i i put it in
no it's like popcorn you don't turn back
to it oh that that form is completely
different though the rice stays the same
i think i think if you took the water
out somehow maybe we could do it
scientists
i mean
i used to
my family uh actually a lot of japanese
families what they do is if they make
too much rice then you put it into like
small you know like maybe microwave size
packets and then you put in the freezer
yes yeah that was also what happened as
well yeah but but it's like not the same
like the next morning you wake up be
like you know okay there's some leftover
rice if i don't eat him my mom's gonna
[ __ ] throw a hissy fit so let's let's
just get it out defrost that [ __ ] but
there was no space in my freezer to put
extra packets of frozen rice do you know
why as a university what happens when
your mom comes over she brings you eight
[ __ ] eight like tupperware boxes full
of takeaway food and then
then you gotta put it in the freezer and
it just lasted it'll last you the entire
day
the entire [ __ ] term i was that
[ __ ] i wasn't that [ __ ] you know
you when you've got to share a freezer
and that some [ __ ] makes takes up the
entire [ __ ] thing because he decided
that his he was going to meal prep like
like an entire month yeah you're like
you're a [ __ ] you know
like we got to share the freezer where
is my ben and jerry's going where am i
going to put my body i just wanted one
ben and jerry's in here is that too much
to ask
you like start playing tetris with all
the rice packets yeah yeah yeah
no because like my mom would come to
visit me once a month in university and
every month she'd bring like two full
like sainsbury's bags worth of like
takeaway boxes holy [ __ ] and i'm just
like that that is i don't know i don't
know how many people were in your like
were you sharing one fridge with
like uh
six or seven or something like that so
at best you get you you have half a
shelf to yourself yeah yeah and then you
have one like a freezer is even smaller
so you had like what two items to put in
the freezer
you must have been hated
i probably
you're sharing this with me yeah that's
my real estate or i'm putting stuff in
there dude you gotta you gotta say about
my property a little bit i'm like i'm
gonna have to pull a shotgun on that
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to haggle with me here you gotta figure
something out
oh god what is uh what it's like living
with a southeast asian guy or girl
that's that's real whenever their
parents come to visit they just bring a
[ __ ] ton of food i don't know why it's
part of like i thought it's just like an
asian in general
is it true with japanese because i don't
i know it's true like southeast asian
and chinese i know when i was living
with i know when i was living on my own
still uh my aunt used to come over and
just like buy me a [ __ ] ton of food and
that that was when i was sharing house
sharing with two other people and yeah i
was also the [ __ ] that took up like
80 of the freezer so i i knew i knew
very well if i'm co-hosting with these
bro
this episode is sponsored by lavoy what
something smells a bit what is this why
is there a pc and dirty laundry on the
table fear not lads for we have the
lavoie air purifier this video is
brought to you by lavoie pc filled with
dust and having a hard time getting
these optimum frames for your game no
worries is your room filled with dirty
laundry and smells horrible not a
problem well perhaps you maybe got some
cat litter giving you some headaches
like male 1 that's just mainland that's
just mainly well lavoie is the perfect
solution for you joe isn't this the sock
that lavoie prepared just for you oh
thank you oh no joy what's in it please
tell me it's not what i think it is
it's not carpool oh my god melin didn't
do anything thank god oh my god the sock
is telling me that gpu lifespan and
performance can be cut by over 50
percent due to overheating commonly
caused by dust oh my god and if you want
to get your very own make sure to click
that link in the description down below
it helps lavoy know to sponsor us again
and the stench is getting purified as we
speak gentlemen so get yourself a boy
air purifier from the description link
below back to the episode did your
parents send you care packages when you
went to university
if i say no they might say otherwise
how dare you don't remember they might
see this episode like we send you things
i don't think they did i i want to say
that
no i don't think so
i remember the last house i moved into
in university
it was like we moved in it was a bit
beat up it wasn't like great
my mom was like mortified she was like
oh my god this place is a [ __ ]
oh my god you can't be caught literally
i'm like it's not that bad
i'll get over it i'll be fine i just
remember her reaction she was just like
i thought she's actually going to be
like you can't you can't you have to
find somewhere else
i was like
it wasn't even that bad it was kind of
messy is this the one in swansea yeah
but it was and that one was the one that
later had like rats
i don't think the rats were a part of
the initial moving in thing i think they
they joined later they moved in with me
they were the other roommates yeah the
package no i didn't i didn't pre-order
those unfortunately
uh yeah no i mean [ __ ] i i think that
everything i i only ever had like white
roommates actually it sounds very i
guess in swanty there isn't much
diversity there was
i did have some friends here from like
uh from from chinese schools mm-hmm but
most of them didn't expect students or
they just a lot of a lot of foreign
students come from right right yeah
there's a there's a very like the uk is
a lot of foreign students yeah i like
sansa um there's a ton of universities i
think there's one every city has two
yeah you guys have like some of the
highest universities yeah yeah yeah and
it's quite a lot of prestigious ones as
well
not swansea
but you know maybe another prestigious
one yeah yeah yeah maybe oxford was full
yeah
yeah so i i had some friends that were
chinese but they didn't speak much
english right right and
there was such a i remember his name
he
i had did some projects with him in
first year and he was like didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on right so we
kind of just helped we were like we'll
just we'll just
help you we'll just do it and he was
like thank you thank you i'll return the
favor
and then you never know we never saw him
never saw him again right and then two
years later same engineering i was like
oh my god i saw him again i was like man
he's and his english was a bit better
yeah yeah
bit more english still wasn't like great
but it was pretty good
and he was really struggling with this
thing and we we had a spare slot in our
group and we were like just just join
ours because we're basically nearly done
yeah go get a passing grade like and he
was like oh [ __ ] no way and i'll be like
what do you do for fun he's like i'll
show you
no dead ass we're like in the like
computer libraries just working on this
thing this is when we like invited him
to join us yeah right and we're like we
were just talking so he was sitting with
us and we were like yeah what do you do
he's like i'll show you so he takes us
outside he starts breakdancing
just like insane like insane yeah insane
because he didn't want to explain it or
something yeah i don't know what it was
he just starts doing like insane like
flips and [ __ ] yeah we were like we're
like computer nerds and like engineers
and we're just like
what
what is this that's [ __ ] awesome he
was so bizarre and then the glow up dude
yeah
and he was like he's like yeah i love
breakdancing it's my passion and stuff
yeah and i was like i was like nice dude
i'm nice she's like what are you gonna
do after this he's like i [ __ ] know
he's like he's like i'm just i'm just
i'm just here until my parents dragged
me back and i was like i have fair
enough breakdance my way to a girl and
so he was like he was like by the way i
didn't forget i wanna i wanna i wanna i
wanna return the favor for you help you
guys help me so much oh yeah yeah and uh
i didn't see him for a long time and
then one day i was on the bus
back to like the
my house and he was there he was like
dude let me return the favor for you
yeah and i was like oh okay sure sure
and so we go into town he's like look my
friend owns this boba store and i'm like
i'm like of course
[Music]
i'm like yeah i don't want to be racist
it makes sense
your chinese friends own the boba store
yeah that makes sense
my first time ever having bobo he's like
yeah you've got to try this this is
amazing oh really you love tea i'm like
yeah i loved it yeah yeah i'd never
heard of boba before right this is just
like 20
is this before it like exploded yeah
this is like
exploding yeah and i've never even seen
this stuff and they were putting these
these what i thought were balls into my
drink tapioca yeah
he puts them in i don't know man it
looks kind of this isn't like tea i've
had before
and it's and it's cold yeah yeah i don't
know about that so i have this and he
makes it for me and it's he's like it's
it's pretty charged
i'm like
how much this work would have cost if i
charged you but all right
i was very grateful and i drink it and
immediately like
i'm like choking on this [ __ ] tapioca
ball i'm like oh
i'm like you got a heimlich
it's awful i like spat out the boba i
mean this joy is so bad
i suck on it like the widest thing ever
that is the wildest story i've ever
heard white man tries tapioca literally
literally spat it out and i was like i'm
sorry i'm so sorry he's like no this is
it was funny and i'm like
i'm like but the milk part the milk pot
tasted good yeah can we get rid of the
balls and he's like yeah we'll just make
you another one without the ball no no
you don't have to he's like it's free
don't worry like
okay i got you bro i was like okay okay
okay that's nice of him yeah he's very
very nice god i remember when the
[ __ ] initial boba explosion happened
in japan how did that happen why did
that happen that's so weird because like
yeah the
the month we moved here it was like
every boba store you could you would
tell which boba store it what was the
burger store sorry
if it had a line outside yeah yeah yeah
there were some barber stores near my
house at the time where it was like
legit like on weekends it was legit like
a four-hour wait yeah and i'm like i
don't get it what i don't get it it's uh
it's just a bit of tea with some jelly
man did that die just oh yeah
like [ __ ] sped run death dude like i
like
speed run death i think it's still yeah
no listen you never see you go to a boba
store now there's like maybe one or two
people there
that's true well this there's still a
thing in the uk from what i can see they
still like exist the stores i don't know
it's like it's still around but it's not
just it's just the hype i mean rightly
so because i thought it was like
overrated the [ __ ] i think so i did i
didn't get what the craze around it was
i mean i drank i drank a shitload of it
during uni because we had like a bubble
store near like where we studied but
like i get it yeah but that was before
the explosion lasts a while because it's
cold so you can kind of just sip on it
throughout the day if you if you ever
get a big one also if you're a uni
student it's a great sugar rush yeah it
also keeps you concentrated i guess
everyone everyone after a while was like
in japan at least we're like all right
back back to starbucks now yeah back to
starting to the way life should have
been i just i just i just i saw nothing
with just iced tea or iced coffee i
don't know maybe
to me it was like honestly but it's not
fun there's no there's no personality
i'm a hot boy i like i like my drinks
hot i don't really like cold drinks
they're hot boba too though right i
think hop over is just not the same it's
not the same
yeah i think they do but it's not it's
not as good i believe you can order it
with like no ice sometimes yeah you know
when you can customize your lukewarm
though
that's lukewarm it's like piss water
yeah i don't know i don't know what
maniac would order warm boba but it was
an option in some of the poker stores
i've been to uh it was like a specialty
i'd i'd be like okay if you say so is
that was that a secret menu did you have
a secret menu
did you have to speak chinese together
it's like i'm a chinese
[Music]
but i remember just like not just in
japan but just pretty much everywhere in
the uk everywhere in thailand you just
couldn't get away from it like even in
the states it was like fashionable i
think this is a fashionable drink yeah i
guess so and i think it's instagramable
you know let's be honest 2014 was just
uh was although like the frappuccino
that's what it was that's right
that was the thing everyone just wants a
photogenic drink and boba looked
photogenic but i feel japan took that
like the photogenic-ness of a boba and
just like was trying to stretch it out
to
such a high degree where it's just so
unnecessary it's like everything in
japan though everything's about taking
photos like afternoon tea i love my
afternoon tea it's the most worst thing
i've ever said i really really enjoy
going for tea and having crumpets or
scones
that is like a weirdly popular
subculture in japan isn't it it is but
everywhere i've been just does it really
badly really they they
okay i mean not badly oh it's hard to
say not as good like i to me afternoon
tea is just as much about like the food
you get as it is the tea yeah right
right and the food isn't great here it's
it's the food here looks so aesthetic
but it doesn't taste good yeah yeah
literally all they do is they they make
they arrange it and they get these like
beautiful colored things then you take
one bite of the quiche you're like why
does it taste bad yes i
actually agree so that this is like
afternoon tea is one thing that england
does
the best that i've had so far because
the the afternoon tea food is actually
good whereas in japan every time i've
had afternoon tea it just looks pretty
also yeah they should it's got to be
layered right yeah so like the layers
are to distinguish the types of flavors
right bottom is for sandwiches then
maybe you get like the the quiches or
the more like savory kind of uh like
kind of the dishes it's always
sandwiches pastries yeah and so so it's
like savory sweet savory and then sweets
yeah but in japan it's sweet
sweet
savory and also sweet but it's like it's
ridiculous it's like this isn't because
normally afternoon tea you kind of have
it like we have in the afternoon yeah
but you know if it's a good place you
can only like skip lunch or dinner with
it because it's pretty like it's quite a
lot yeah some places even refill yeah in
the uk they refill the sandwiches or
stuff in some places so you can just
like you can chow down yeah if you like
the sandwiches or you like the whatever
they're offering dude it's good it's so
good money's worth yeah expensive though
in london it's very expensive yeah i bet
yeah it's good it's really good right
but it's an experience you're paying for
right yeah yeah yeah
one thing i've only seen really in asia
as well going off like the boba thing
before like i guess the boba questions
the coolest thing i've ever mentioned by
the way i just realized that it was also
privileged maybe like the tea isn't good
enough
it's disgusting no sandwiches i mean i
mean it's one thing i feel like britain
does well so i i think it's a good it's
not
it's yeah like uh
dessert dessert cafes that's that's one
thing like i only saw in asia oh yeah
and i don't i don't know if there is
more dessert cafes
dessert buffets
what's that it's it's like it's
literally exactly that think of a buffet
but it's all desserts yeah because
whenever i'd hang out with my uh like
some of my friends in thailand they'd be
like oh let's go to this dessert cafe
i'm just like wait like to me growing up
in england dessert was something you
have at the end of a meal at a
restaurant yeah you don't go to a
specific place to eat dessert right that
was that concept was just alien to me
yeah and like i to me it still feels
weird right because
i would like if i want dessert after a
meal i would order it at the restaurant
yeah but like you go to a dessert cafe
and it's like
it's like half a meal you know
you know you know because like you never
you never go to a dessert cafe after you
finish eating at a restaurant yeah but
you go to a dessert cafe at like really
weird times the other day
yeah yeah three or something i go to a
dessert cafe i have to dessert and then
it just [ __ ] with my eating schedule
because then i just don't want dinner
yeah then it also doesn't fill me up as
well it's it's really weird so you get
hungry at like 9 p.m yeah it's like a
really weird time where it's like oh
it's kind of too late to eat food yeah
all right
but i'm i know i won't be able to sleep
because i'm going to get hungry yeah
yeah no i get that yeah i don't want it
i don't know i just don't feel satisfied
if i've eaten a lot of something sweet
but yeah when i eat like a savory meal
yeah i just feel like happy i just feel
sick if i eat too much sweet stuff now
yeah yeah i was always like that though
like i could never eat two i liked
sweets but like i could never eat too
much of it because then i just get i'd
be filled up but then the that feeling
of being filled up by sweet [ __ ] just
made me feel really ill
which just made me want to eat regular
food anyway man i i said this uh like
a year or two ago but man i still don't
like
themed cafes in japan
they're like collaboration cafes
the food because of the food the food
and drink is like a jerk it looks good
that's the thing is that i hate the fact
that we're turning like food impractical
we're like we're cha we're like okay
well we put a little uh i went to the
square enix one oh yeah and then they
made me a latte and i was like this
latte tastes really bad yeah yeah but
they put a slime on it so i guess now
it's worth nine dollars
like
what
uh there's only been i've been to so
many themed cafes because aki loves
going to them i know um like because she
makes content out of it so it's
understandable but uh the i think the
only
good one where i would actually go back
for the food is the kirby cafe
and i know it's good
[Music]
thing at uh [ __ ] tokyo skytree but
now they made it made it a permanent
thing so you know if a themed cafe turns
permanent that's how you know that the
food is good
because if the food sucks then people
don't come back it's like a novelty to
it that's really short-lived
and once you've like experienced all the
food and you've experienced that themed
cafes like you know style and everything
and you've got grabbed all the [ __ ]
merch you can because there's always a
merch shop attached to it as well then
you're not gonna go back i don't know
because to me it's like the food itself
is is the art yeah don't draw all over
my steak don't reassemble the carrots to
look like a smiley face but i think
that's why i like the kirby cafe because
the kirby cafe they don't [ __ ] around
with the food they [ __ ] around with the
cutlery so like the plates are like
certainly shaped like shaped in certain
ways or like the cups are shaped in
certain ways but the actual food itself
is
normal once you once you put it on a
regular plate i don't know if i'm like a
scrooge or something just don't enjoy
fun or whatever but like i just don't
want people like making faces or [ __ ]
out with my food i don't want my food to
be like a toy no i get i i i'm exactly
the same way where if i go to a themed
something of like something i'm a fan of
then i don't want them to [ __ ] around
with the food
look look i'm i'm here for a good time
to enjoy the thing i like i'll buy them
give me like cool merch give me like
cool exclusive merch that i can buy yeah
better way to get one with the show than
to digest the show
i'll do like [ __ ] typical example was
when we went to the bucky exhibit right
yeah and i saw this poster that was like
oh just down the block there is a the
bucky cafe like a bucky themed cafe and
my friend and i were like because you
know i was like hitting around you know
lunchtime like early afternoon we were
like all right let's let's let's go
check it out all right let's let's go
see the menu and i saw the menu and i
was like this is the laziest attempt at
a themed cafe one of them was like
retsukaio's neapolitan pasta and i'm
like what the when does retsu ever eat
napoleon pasta
in [ __ ] bucky it's like they are
really [ __ ] stretching it they're
like they're really stretching it to
make it on brian yeah it's mickey
mouse's world famous lasagna yeah it was
like one of those like one of them was
like eugero's cappuccino and it's like
it didn't even have user's face on it it
was literally just a cappuccino
yeah nine dollars
like what makes this huge that's that's
the thing about
so many themed cafes i'm into in japan
where the they have a dish on the menu
that's just like you know [ __ ] uh
rin's special curry from fate stay night
and i'm just like when when did this
happen
how was this on brand why did you just
add you literally just added a character
to a random dish yeah
you called it you call it brand oh my
gosh
i find it like insulting it's like
you're you're you're insulting my
intelligence yeah you're assaulting my
fandom yeah yeah like you think i'm just
gonna buy this because you put this
character on i'll take two but
but like like if you if you had put the
[ __ ] like
monopoles and pasta in front of me i
would have been like oh it's just the
real nepalese pasta like do you think
though if if they were like but it's
retsukayos napolitan pasta then i'd be
like well [ __ ] sign me up then i'm
gonna eat the [ __ ] out of this like this
is why like when you go to like wolfgang
puck's restaurant he doesn't serve like
[ __ ] smiley faces on his steak you
know what i mean like i just don't want
i just don't want that like i don't want
this yeah it's like the steaks if you
went to a
to me it's like it's such if a food is
done well it itself is so beautiful now
pay for it yeah it speaks more but you
know just have the decor of the cafe
have everything else be like just maybe
just just make it like everything else
but the food yeah yeah
have cool cutlery have a cool vibe you
know have a have a cool aesthetic you
know make make it feel like you're
actually if it's a kirby make it so that
the toilet is kirby and i can lift up
his face
yeah and i can sit and [ __ ] and cook
i think that's what i appreciated about
the kirby cafe was that they didn't [ __ ]
around with the food they [ __ ] around
with the cutlery which you can then buy
at the [ __ ] merch store right so i
was like oh cool this is like a thing i
can use in my kitchen and it's like kind
of neat and dope and it doesn't have to
i don't have to make a [ __ ] kirby if
you come to japan at some point i'm sure
there'll be tons yeah please like kobe
cafe is great um but like it's always a
bunch
but like you know for like for me
especially if when it's like cafes
especially that are like paired with
like exhibits or whatever right it's
just like just just give me some good
merch didn't they have the pen pineapple
pen cafe yeah i went to did they
actually
[ __ ] work i made a video on it yeah
yeah you did right yeah i mean the media
was this
when was pen pineapple
like six years ago six years ago i think
it was like 2016. yeah they made it
a cafe they made a pop-up of pin
pineapple apple panda i think it was at
tokyo skytree or tokyo tower whichever
one it was right uh but yeah you go in
and uh all of the menu items spelt out
ppap uh you know because that was the
only thing that was it yeah they didn't
even have any uh like pineapple or apple
based products and i'm like i feel like
you really missed the ball
it's paprika right it was like a pen
pineapple apple pen burger and i'm like
what does this have to do with bam
pineapple apple bam with the zero
pineapple in the middle yeah no
pineapple in the burger no apple that's
good though
i don't mind it if it's done well but
like even then it's like they couldn't
even put the effort to do that and it's
like oh the thing i felt the most sorry
about was the fact that
like i looked at there was like two like
clerks who were like standing behind the
counter and they looked so dead inside
because penn pineapple apple was playing
on repeat in the store
all day i was there for like a couple of
hours and i was like by like minute 20 i
was like i want to get the [ __ ] out of
here just like just shove a pen in my
ear just like blur out the sound they
look so dead well that's that's kind of
how i feel like all of the truck drivers
who drive around like [ __ ] harajuku
or whatever and they have to drive
around promoting these idols or whatever
oh yeah
album yeah have we spoke about i swear
we've mentioned it there's these trucks
that drive around japan where they'll
play music
yeah yeah really loudly yeah they're
called
or decorative trucks yeah yeah just
blame you and they're awesome they're
awful it's basically just like a moving
billboard basically yeah basically weird
in japan
you can't make noise in your own
apartment but anyone can make as much
noise as they want on the street it's
really weird yeah right like someone can
come around
hot potatoes and uh
intrude our like streams
yeah running for government just scream
in public yeah
it's just like what year are we in where
you don't don't you have like social
media that you could promote uh no but
no i'm sure you're really connected with
the youth of today by driving around a
truck and you're like what do they
expect for like everyone to come out of
their houses it's like guys honey wake
up
let's open your politicians in town
i mean even if it's old older people
right
they're not gonna get up to go outside
to listen to you drive by maybe that's
why they're loud otherwise they're not
gonna like hear it right so they just
like broadcast
they broadcast all the houses
probably honestly probably we're going
to make it through the hearing aids
it trends in an interesting spot where
like they have to
uh political people have to try and go
towards the older generation yeah so all
the techniques they use seem like
archaic as [ __ ] but it's the only way
they can get elected because if you're
not in someone's letterbox they're not
they're they're not getting
interestingly weird isn't it weird
they're like they're just the whole
political system is just catered to well
what i just don't understand though is
like yeah i'm sure they're like you know
being loud as [ __ ] right on the streets
so that again as you were saying late
then it can reach the old people's ears
right yeah a lot of people you know as
old age comes naturally you become hard
of hearing and yet these same old people
can hear like the tiniest creek from
upstairs and be like oh my god that's
too [ __ ] loud
how dare they walk so loud in my
apartment meanwhile i'm having a really
hard time hearing this [ __ ]
politician on 17 megaphones just drive
past my house you know i need them turn
up a little bit louder
well i don't know what like are there
any laws around like how much noise you
can make in japan
because it's something like that i don't
know like
i don't know i feel i feel half the time
like people just don't follow those laws
yeah and there's like always exceptions
to the rule like you know you could have
like a bunch of like like how come you
know all these like loud ass bikes that
like drive through like neighborhoods
and you know not be [ __ ] yeah called
on by the cops
does your neighborhood have like uh a
gang of old japanese grandmas who are
just like who are just like who are just
like the real
you know
the leaders of that [ __ ] street or
whatever because you have a house oh
yeah i have a house yeah yeah you're in
like a neighborhood area yeah i'm in an
apartment so yeah okay yeah i'm in an
apartment as well yeah because melin
like warned me about this before before
i was moving in the house and she was
like be careful about the posse of old
japanese grandmas and i'm just like what
are you talking about melin what are you
talking about and lo and behold like
like now i've noticed like there's there
is this group of japanese grandmas who
like seem to run the neighborhood i
don't i don't know i don't know how this
happens i don't know why this happened
but you do one you do like one thing
wrong like maybe you take the garbage
out just a bit too early you see them
you see them eyeing you you see them
eyeing you right yeah i can tell any
time any time me and sydney come out
like we could we like sometimes they're
just like gossiping together right like
you know when you can you know when you
could feel someone gossiping about you
that's every time like me and sydney go
out of the house and like they're always
in the same corner it's the same group
of same group of japanese grandma and i
remember we should wait for them and say
hi yeah yeah you should i do yeah for
those people you what i've learned is
that you just need to be like ignorantly
like happy and friendly towards them and
then they'll start to be like oh maybe
maybe they're actually all right maybe
we'll we'll take them off the hit list
you know
i feel like okay i feel like i've been
put i was friendly enough right i was
the most moist
yeah but
i i i feel like i've been put on a hit
list now because uh i did unfortunately
take the garbage out on the wrong day
one day
being on a japanese hit list is just
like i'll give you at worst a passive
aggressive note one day yeah i got that
yeah yeah yeah did you remember yeah i
remember i in my old apartment i got
that english written note yeah yeah
that's the worst you'll get yeah they
say
they say they'll kick you out and then
they'll they'll tell the housing company
and then i need hong kong
card and then they shut up yeah the
housing company is not going to kick you
out of course unless you're out actually
taking the piss but if you're just
walking they're not gonna then the
housing companies not gonna give a [ __ ]
yeah they'll be like okay granny they'll
be like all right simmer down come on
so yeah say one one day like uh
normally we take our garbage out either
like the night before or like the
morning of i don't know what's custom in
in japanese neighborhoods normally it
depends on your area yeah normally it's
like i think the morning of yeah but i
remember i think we woke i woke up like
slightly late that day yeah so how it
works in my place is that um the garbage
is one day and then like the recyclables
is the next day
um
i think that's most i think it's most
places yeah yes so
i i thought like i was just on the cusp
of like getting like uh getting the
recyclables out on the right day yeah
because it's garbage recyclables then
garbage again yeah um and so i thought i
was just on the cast maybe maybe the
garbage truck hadn't come yet so i go
out to the garbage sport and i see like
some bags there i was like oh great i
still i still
met uh i still made it in time yeah and
so i put i put the recyclables out went
back in my house and just continued
about my day and then i i get i get a
ring on my doorbell oh no i'm gonna ring
my doorbell and i'm just like and i'm
just like oh it must be uh it must be a
delivery or something yeah and it's uh i
opened the door and it's a
three-year-old japanese grandmaster just
staring at me
yeah i
and i see my uh my bag of recyclables
right uh right uh right in front of my
door right and uh they um i mean they
they they nicely enough explained to me
that uh it was uh that i had missed the
time and it was the wrong day to bring
out the to bring out the recyclables but
it kind of felt like some [ __ ] loan
sharks outside my door being being like
it would be a shame if this would have
happened again yeah yeah like repo
man you do it again we're taking
everything they are basically like the
gangsters that run the neighborhood you
know i felt like i just like missed out
on the day a lot on like paying the
protection money of the day it's like
shame shame what would happen if america
has the crips and the blood so we have
the grannies
fear them
they control everything yeah they they
they're the real like
it's like the [ __ ] sopranos right you
know it's the japanese sopranos right
the old japanese groundbreaking
some really strict crazy grandmas you
can get pissed off when like you know on
like cardboard boxes yeah like the
amazon labels and stuff they get like
pissed off you don't take those oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah some grandmas that get
yeah even though it doesn't doesn't make
a difference yeah of course
this is why i love love living in an
apartment building i just take it down
whenever i want yeah yeah no no
recycling day
no garbage day whenever you have garbage
take it down cardboard's the worst
because when you're moving in it
literally is like cardboard city oh yeah
yeah and it's just like stacks upon
stacks upon stack and waiting for the
day when you're like well what's that in
the corner well it's the wall of
cardboard actually one of the main
attractions of the apartment and i have
so much cardboard in fact that i could
probably uh you know house everyone in
the half of japan yeah i mean that's
that's the thing where i remember when i
was moving in i
i felt like
if you missed the day of the cardboard
collection then you were just like you
were just [ __ ] right yeah yeah but
also you feel like am i taking the piss
with this much cardboard like i have
like
like a two meter high stack of cardboard
am i am i taking up too much cardboard
is that allowed what's the limit on how
much recycling i can recycle i remember
the only time i had like a granny
experience uh
uh when i was moving into my current
place was when when it was like the
first week i was moving in and you know
it was like the shitload of cardboard
right yeah yeah and cardboard day comes
around i'm just like finally here we go
this is this is where the cleansing
starts right so i i take out like way
too much cardboard like probably [ __ ]
half the amazon rainforest worth of
cardboard right naturally and then uh
and then uh that the next morning i i
come out you know to leave for the
office right and and a grandma like
stops me
and she's and i'm like oh no
oh wow
and uh she points at the mountain of
cardboard and she's like
that's that's all your cardboard right
yeah and i was like i mean not all of it
but yeah like come on laura's like
ninety percent it's like it's like like
yeah most of it and she's like i think
uh that you know you're really causing
the the you know rubbish people a lot of
trouble with that much cardboard and
then i just reverse uno card and i'm
like i moved in yesterday put some
sunglasses
off
but was just like oh i'm sorry then i'm
sorry about that
yeah but that felt good that was the one
time where i trumped the granny i was
like you don't control it
silence silas woman you could actually
um some moving companies alive like call
them up yeah yeah yeah yeah i did that
but even they i had so much cardboard
that the moving company could only take
so much yeah cardboard yeah because i
bought like because i bought because you
know i moved into a much bigger place
and i needed to buy all this new
furniture to fill up the space so yeah
yeah but it's not good felt good to
reverse
granny basically you know they think
like organized crime in japan is the
yakuza no just it's the great it's the
japanese grannies in your neighborhood
watch out make sure you don't piss them
off yeah otherwise you're gonna be
having a bad time i've been leaving here
for six years i know every nook and
cranny of these streets literally the
day after they came like i came back i
came back home and uh they slid this in
my letterbox just like the schedule the
garbage for like the week and the
garbage collection
i was just like i was just like oh this
is they're sending me a message
they're literally sending me a message
and you're like get this wrong again
don't [ __ ] it up again
i'm gonna wake up in my bed with like a
decapitated horsehead
like
don't get the guy get the garbage day
right next time don't [ __ ] up
dad's shaman at your friend
so you better take this out on the right
day
what day what day does oily containers
go gone
a shampoo bottle is not recycling cons
oh my god
i love it you have this like spreadsheet
of like items that very specifically
cannot be recycled and stuff i have an
app for it dude oh my god yeah like our
ward created an app being like if you
put in a certain item it tells you
exactly what day what sucks is that
there's like some items you're like what
the [ __ ] is this it's like it's like you
know like styrofoam right yeah where
have you had that packaging that's like
thin
it's like a paper styrofoam yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] is this is this burnable
is this paper is this plastic i don't
know what this is this is a mystery and
every time i ask anyone that i have no
idea i i think it's burnable but no
one's like 100 they're like
everyone's like dude it's not going to
matter
that's the thing it's like there's all
these rules that are laid out that like
the grannies will enforce you on but
like yeah when you put it all into a
[ __ ] bag and just put it out i heard
i heard i heard that apparently the
recycling even though they they make you
shorter very strict that actually when
it goes to the plant apparently i don't
know how true this is it's not actually
like they don't recycle it as well as
you think they are yeah yeah yeah
i would believe that yeah i mean fair
enough yeah um but [ __ ] dude i i one
time i went down to my recycling thing
in my current place
i thought hmm
i was just i was putting out my bottles
in the bottle thing i noticed that there
was like
10 plus
bombay sapphire
gin bottles right and i was like
who has drank this much bombay sapphire
this is a lot wasn't you right it
wouldn't it wasn't
i was gonna say i thought that was like
as another person who enjoys bombay
sanctuary and i was like huh i wonder
who's bought this much bombay well i'm
gonna keep saying it's very satisfying
bomb based sapphire there's another
british person in your building i was
like either somebody's
running a bar secretly in their
apartment that specializes in bombay
sapphire cocktails someone had a good
night well there's a really depressed
british person somewhere in this
apartment building who is really
really spending a lot of money on gin
yeah i just thought why would you have
this many they're all neatly stacked
like almost like a jenga-esque stacking
style i'm like this is impressive this
is definitely one person who brought i
wonder did they collect them for a long
time they thought no this is ridiculous
i can't i can't collect this many
bottles because some people keep their
alcohol containers afterwards yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like a a memory but yeah
i guess when you drink too much you're
like yeah okay this is just how many how
many bombay sapphires is too many i just
thought i was like this is a lot i'm
like yeah what's going on here i i
wonder i was like what a weird trash do
you even see people's trash and you
think what's going on oh yeah yeah
many times i remember the weirdest one i
saw was uh it was a vacuum cleaner that
had been perfectly cut in half down
it was like a dyson it was like the body
of a dyson but had been perfectly split
down the middle but there was only one
half and i'm like where did the other
half go there's a serial killer yeah
just one half yeah it was only one half
and i was i was kind of i was like for
like five minutes i was kind of looking
around seeing like i wonder where the
other half is i couldn't find it so he's
either kept the other half or i've
witnessed uh some crucial evidence of a
crime scene or something like i don't i
don't know what
it was the weirdest thing at least i was
like oh well now i know what's inside of
a dyson
that's like something you see like a
youtube channel yeah
what's inside of a dice what's inside of
a dicer what if i cut this dyson in
perfectly i just wanted i just want to
know how they did it
they must have like that it's either
someone has a laser cutter inside of
their house or they just went ham with a
saw i don't know what it was either they
have a shore in their house yeah it's
somewhere else and then they brought
half a dozen to your apartment
building and then they decided that they
are done with half a dice and they're
gonna throw it away it was the weirdest
thing i've ever seen so annoying having
to get rid of big stuff in japan it is
to buy those stupid stickers from the
convenient and then you can't throw out
a
if it's bigger than i think 30
centimeters in my opinion yeah something
like that which is nothing yeah there's
so many things that are 30 centimeters
or bigger and if you want to throw it
away you have to book and it's normally
like three weeks away if you're lucky
yeah usually it's like a month so
normally now i figured out a genius
strat which is just break the thing down
yeah below 30 seconds oh yeah yeah yeah
and then you're good yeah yeah it's like
it's like uh you know how like in the
prison movies right when they when they
escape from prison that they start
dumping the soil like one by one yeah in
the courtyard or something yeah yeah
it's like you gotta you gotta break this
wall this cabinet into like small pieces
and slowly recycle it every
week actually people do it because they
don't want to deal with because this
[ __ ] is showing
someone had disposed of an office chair
one part at a time
i get it i get it that's very genius i
remember because like i remember seeing
like i would go take the garbage out and
one day i'd saw like the bottom of like
the wheels part and i'm just like why
someone just getting rid of like the
[ __ ] wheels part and then the next
week i go and go go to put the garbage
again and it's like the seat
then this is it's the seat and i'm like
oh someone's just playing jenga with
office chairs and then next week should
learn hold it's like the black rest it's
slow but it's a fake this is the exact
reason why i bought a saw
i'm not kidding i bought a sword just to
source [ __ ] oh yeah yeah i don't have to
deal with it i like a lot of wooden [ __ ]
and i'm just like i'm not paying to get
rid of this [ __ ] wooden plank i'm
just going to saw this yeah but it's
also it's also annoying because you have
to you have to measure it exactly yeah
yeah and if it's even a little bit off
that whether they won't take it yeah you
need to wait another three weeks and buy
those stupid sticker things again i i
don't know i had like a metallic like
coat hanger or coat rack kind of thing
and of course it was like way too big
even if i took the parts off so what did
i do i i put it back up i put it on my
balcony and just let the weather wear it
down as much as possible so the point
where i could just snap it in here you
let it rust
i just let it rust to [ __ ] and then i
grab the saw or like just snap it in
half to the size i'm like perfect just
let nature take its course
it
erosion
like three months later i was like all
right i can finally see the worst way to
recycle something but i respect i
respect the the the effort you'd go to
to not deal with the beauty yeah yeah
dude it probably would have taken just
as long to [ __ ] book a time to throw
this [ __ ] code hanger out
i just don't want to deal with it yeah i
just or i just wait for someone to come
over and be like do you want this shitty
thing i don't need just take it dude
they make me feel like such a bastard
for using batteries like i just i just
want to use some double-a batteries yeah
and they make it seem like i i was like
like using like some kind of radioactive
material the way that i get rid of it
i'm like what's wrong with me yeah i
don't think i've ever like properly
gotten rid of my batteries right because
i'm just like okay i'll get rid of them
next time the other time um so i have
like a [ __ ] draw just full of like
use dead batteries that i've not been
able to get rid of because that is the
most drawn existence yeah oh i'm sure
we've got a whole drawer full of battery
sydney go go grab a pair none of them
are working god that's what you should
do is like a joke just be like just get
one like actually working battery and
put it in that drone being like there
was one working battery
in the world
i mean i'm something special i'm gonna
get rid of it someday but just like i i
just keep forgetting the day to get rid
of the batteries like the most [ __ ] up
saw trap
there is one working battery you have 15
minutes
[Music]
find the working battery
oh my god yeah i don't really use a lot
of batteries but for a lot of the uh
filming stuff that we have yeah it's
basically all for the filming stuff for
like yeah mics camera accessories it's
all batteries it's really annoying
because you have to
have to get batteries for that and it
kind of sucks i was like get
rechargeable ones yeah but i always
forget to recharge yeah yeah but then if
you get rechargeable ones you forget to
recharge the before the shoots which is
yeah and luckily you can buy aaa
batteries like everywhere yeah so yeah
pretty good for that it's pretty good
always always done well
anything else you guys have been up to
this week just trying to think we watch
down with me
finished odd text
oh you finished odd taxi
that's that's surprising did you watch
it and subbed or dubbed stopped it was
good i liked it yeah nice a very fun
show i don't know how they're gonna make
a movie
oh yeah they are making a movie aren't
they yeah i was i was surprised when
they announced that they were making a
movie just because
it felt like it just wrapped everything
up yeah i was like we're done aren't we
also it weirdly seemed like i didn't
think it was as popular on the surface
she made it out to be i i watched it
yeah i ended up watching it yeah yeah
oh have we never talked about it i don't
know
wait i thought i told you i finished it
no you
no you didn't no i would remember
because it's so rare
i would remember if you told me you
finished an anime joey what the [ __ ] i
liked it
yeah i liked it it was good but yeah
again like i was surprised not only
because yeah as you said like the the
show wrapped up nicely where it was like
how are they going to make a movie out
of it but also it's like i don't know i
feel odd texture is one of those shows
where like it got really popular from
word of mouth yeah where like
is it like i was like did it really get
that popular to warrant a movie
i don't know how popular it got because
i remember when i made my video on it i
was just like i made it because no one
was talking about it yeah right at all
and i thought it was kind of like the
underdog i mean everyone who watches it
i know likes it yeah yeah yeah but
that's the thing it's like it's one of
those shows where like i feel you start
watching it because someone who gave it
a go was like it was really [ __ ] good
yeah i feel like it had a similar arc to
a maiden abyss because when maiden abyss
came out it just no one was watching
made in abyss at all because everyone
saw the art style and everyone was just
like oh it's this is children's show
children's show which couldn't be more
further from the truth honestly um but
then like there's a lot of children in
the show
i mean yeah it is a children's show
yeah that's one for the kids
one for the whole thing they can relate
the children's community
the children can relate
which is uh
um but yeah i mean like
it kind of like that was another show
that really spread through word of mouth
and then eventually like one like anime
of the year the year it came out yeah uh
odd taxi i feel had a similar thing
where it didn't really have much
promotion or anything like that at least
not not that i could see outside of
japan in japan it actually had some
kind of decent promotion because every
time i remember when it was airing every
time you go in a taxi they would have an
odd taxi
advertisement
yeah yeah did you not see no i didn't
like they always have it like playing um
in like you know the little tvs that i
have on yeah
taxis
yeah at least i did i saw them i think i
didn't go on enough taxis
did we
talk about tokyo avengers i watched that
i think you have not talked about it
tokyo maybe not maybe not an episode
well i was kind of i was trying to watch
all the animes of the year that were
nominated
um when did you get time to watch anime
just go i mean an episode here and there
it's very sporadic right um i was like
oh sunnyboy looks
kind of [ __ ] i i didn't yeah you're not
going to enjoy sunnyvale i looked at it
and i was like oh yeah it's it's for
those anime fans that think that they're
really intelligent and want something
deep
your iq wasn't happening
at the end of the day
who would enjoy sunny boy i think you
would really enjoy sonny boy actually
what okay you are not listening you're
the first person to say that some reason
i don't know if i should be offended
there's this category of shows and to me
i took one look at sunny boy and i was
like oh this is what [ __ ] reddit
anime fans are gonna be like this this
is the best anime of the year actually
it's like
i listened to two soundtrack songs from
it and i was like okay if the soundtrack
is as good as the actual show i think
i'm gonna enjoy this i just can't i just
cannot stand shows right i feel like
people like it just to be pretentious
right and that's like one of those shows
that like i felt like the fans make me
want to not watch it and despite it more
than the show yeah i get that yeah i
mean like i
i don't even know if i enjoyed sunny boy
uh it's it's a really [ __ ] weird show
and it left an impression on me whether
i enjoyed it or not oh that sounds like
something
yeah i i watched it and i'm just like
this is such a jokey show i've been like
did you give it out of 10. i don't even
[ __ ] know like
to me it's still like to me like to me
like it's still sinking in it could be
like it's it's one of those mean what
does it [ __ ] mean
what is it okay
i got the perfect analogy have you
watched like donnie darko yeah what did
you think of it i looked down darker
what did you like about it
oh it's been so long exactly
i remember i liked it it's been a very
long time since i watched dollyarco yeah
like one of my favorite movies
okay so it's kind of like can you watch
it so then i don't feel bad about
[ __ ] on it because right now i just
feel like i'm [ __ ] into the void
it's like it's like
yeah it's like 86 when i [ __ ] on 86 i
thought oh no one's going to contest me
on this turned out meanwhile the entire
interview i'm really [ __ ] angry yeah
i didn't like 86 but to be fair i
watched episodes of that and it was
boring as [ __ ] yeah that's 86 his fault
sunny boy is just 12. sunny boys just 12
episodes um it's like what actually like
because i remember watching the first
three episodes of sunnybrook i thought
it was boring as [ __ ] i thought it was
like boring as [ __ ] this is like if you
this is like this is like holy [ __ ] i'm
gonna be like this is like [ __ ] art
house [ __ ] pretentious [ __ ] um and
then like the soundtrack got recommended
to me and i'm just like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah this soundtrack just like is
everything i want it's like a lot of
soft frog alternative rock in the
soundtrack yeah you listen to some
tracks and i'm just like i kind of want
to watch the show just because it's yeah
it sounds right i found it because i was
buying a bunch of vinyls and yeah on the
front page of the store that the online
store that i go to buy my vinyls it just
would not leave the front page and i was
like what is this
sunny boy thing so i went onto youtube
real quick looked up one song and i was
like yep sold yeah right yeah right and
that's like the best thing i could say
is like the soundtrack just sets the
vibe of the anime okay yeah where it's
less about the plot points and it's more
about the feeling that it gives you did
you end up finishing it oh yeah i did
then i'm finishing it um i mean like i i
finished it and i didn't know what to
think about it but i like i knew like
some of the ideas presented in sunny boy
it's just kind of like it's one of those
shows that
you don't know exactly what you think
immediately but
the like i i just remember some scenes
so it's kind of like fully cooling in
that sense yeah kind of kind of like
fully cool right right where it's just
like fully coolly donny darker that kind
of thing where you're watching you're
like i don't really know what i watched
but some parts of it just really stick
with you and just refuse to leave right
that's how i feel with sunny boy yeah
yeah do you think it deserves to be
nominated for an anime of the year i
don't think it deserved to be nominated
for anime of the year didn't it win like
the reddit one though like the reddit
yeah yeah of course it is
which doesn't help which does not help
its uh image at all yeah the reddit
armchair critics uh gave it the the
award for like anime you know i hate
bashing on low hanging fruit but yeah i
mean that is sometimes normally the
indication like
yeah i mean like i know whenever i say
like donnie dog is one of my favorite
movies i'm i'm waiting for it like i'm
i'm like dangling the low hanging fruit
no it's normally joking okay he's
normally that guy in our podcast he's
like the pretentious
with donnie darker did you like it
immediately no yeah no i i only liked it
maybe after like my second or third
viewing young when i watched it yeah
yeah exactly yeah that was the problem
like when i first watched it i was like
maybe like 13 14 years old right and
when you watch when you watch those
kinds of movies at 13 14. you don't know
what the [ __ ] going on all you think
is oh creepy bunny wow yeah but then i
watched it again when i was like 17 18
which is like the peak of
pretentiousness well when it comes to
consuming media i definitely had that
face
yeah do you understand donnie darko
only after i watch like a [ __ ] load of
like analysis videos on it right uh but
like i had i had a friend who
recommended me donnie darko during like
high school or like middle school uh who
was like a massive fan of it so like he
would tell me like his theories on it
and we would kind of like bounce off
ideas and i'm like i found that i think
that's the reason why i like a lot of
those kinds of media because it's like
especially when you have another person
or like a group of people to like
discuss it and like kind of like
theorize and hypothesize like oh this
might be this or this might be that
whatever right like that's kind of fun
um and then you know once you actually
like sit down and like read into what
it's actually about according to the
creator or whatever then you just
realize oh it's not as deep as all these
[ __ ] pretentious
critics made it out to be my favorite
thing is when uh people like speculate
about media and stuff and then the
creator was like no that's not it and
then if they're like no no no no i don't
think you i don't think you understood
what you did i think it's actually this
shirt
my theory is right please uh yeah i know
i mean yeah i i i think there's anime
that don't appeal to me as much
unfortunately yeah no and i totally
don't blame you no like it doesn't even
appeal to me it's just like i i have to
be i have to be like
in a really specific mood that comes
along once a year or once every two
years where i'm just like i just want to
watch something and just not understand
it and make me feel things that i mean
the thing i like about this podcast is
that
the viewers can like align their
who they trust's opinion on the show
based on what type of media they like
right so if you if you get if you're
like more to me i'm like and i'm like i
don't like 86 and i'm like you shouldn't
then trust my opinion for other anime
right yeah because like that's like that
show of weirdly is like people are
obsessed with it
and i just didn't enjoy it i didn't know
anything about the series i didn't know
anyone was talking about it yeah i just
didn't like it yeah but i i think it's
like i think part of being a good critic
uh at least or like or talk like on the
online at least or part of being a good
critic is acknowledging that you have
taste because look at like people who
talk about media online and they should
be like you should be able to judge
every single piece of media objectively
equally you know you could you should be
able to be able to judge them with no
bias and i'm just like that's completely
[ __ ] yeah like like you're not a
[ __ ] robot yeah like when i look at
you know for example like donkey for
example when i look at one of his video
game reviews i know exactly what his
taste is and that gives me a better
perspective than a lot of [ __ ] ign
reviewers right yeah because at least
when donkey like i think recently like i
saw his review of like horizon forbidden
west and like he like he didn't like
he's completely he could [ __ ] okay he
like he's shackled i'm not not
completely like compared to some jrpgs
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like i i saw his
criticisms and i was just like wow that
this is like i can completely understand
why he feels this way yeah and i ca and
like but me knowing what kind of gaming
game
i understand and that gives me a better
perspective of what this game is like
compared to a lot of other critics yeah
i would say like the best critics online
are the ones where you continue to keep
watching even though you disagree with
most of their opinions yeah just because
like they because their opinion
holds like even though you don't agree
with it they explain it and they're
articulate enough and they're honest
enough with what they like and the fact
that you know there's no way to
completely get rid of bias with anything
and they own that and you're like well
you know i knew before coming into this
review that you were probably going to
think a certain way about it and i might
not agree with it but i respect the fact
that you can still stick to this yeah
because it's just like probably
everything i like in the game conor's
going to complain about exactly just
like i you know and vice versa yeah yeah
and and vice versa you know but that
just comes with our taste and games yeah
and that's fine it's the same could be
said about anime and stuff yeah i think
i cut you off there no no no no no no no
i didn't know what i was even going to
say yeah yeah yeah tech avengers is okay
i really like the first half
and then it got really [ __ ]
and now he's gonna have tokyo revenge's
fans on his throat turkey avengers was
like i saw the first four episodes and
i'm just like this is a read the manga
show like i definitely felt that you
know what i mean like like
there's like a fight at the end have you
watched all of any anyone watched all of
it here
i i watched the first like two episodes
there's um there's this fight that goes
on for like nine or [ __ ] nine or
eight episodes at the end
and it is like the dumbest fight i've
ever seen in my life that sounds like
some eyes and [ __ ] dude it's like it's
like
it's like just constantly it is
literally the fight of wait there's more
yeah something happens wait there's more
wait there's more and it's like this is
stupid just just [ __ ] resolve it this
is ridiculous this isn't dragon ball
it's like every dress
the story has been somewhat concise yeah
they drag on a little bit here and there
yeah they have had some long fights but
never more than four or five episodes i
think it was just it just felt like this
last fight in particular just took the
absolute piss yeah to the point where i
was like this is just stupid yeah and
yeah i had a good cliffhanger but like
the the last i was so bored for like
four episodes but it doesn't matter man
all the characters are hot as [ __ ] but
like according to the fan base
characters and like yeah i like some of
the characters in the show but
my god are so many of them insufferable
and like i i just oh god i mean i like
the show i thought it was good but [ __ ]
man i felt like it just it like
it like blew its load and then it just
like is it even over is it even over no
it's not over it's not
and i feel like where they left it was
pretty good and it might it might pick
up but like it just felt like every
single time something happened it was
like oh my god there's more oh my god
there's more i don't know like i know
this is gonna sound really unfair this
is totally my bias but like i i think i
only managed to make it through like the
first two or three episodes because i
immediately saw what
kind of theming they were going for with
the story you know like just like a
bunch of dudes just like you know
fighting you know you know it's just
weird as well good stuff but it might i
hate the fact that the moment i knew
where the story was heading in my head i
was immediately just like
i'd just rather read bucky to be honest
i was kind of pissed off as well that
like all of these kids are like 13 14.
yeah i was like why not why just make
them seventeen it would make this story
so it's a little weird that you felt so
much makes so much more sense but here's
the thing isn't it weird that you felt
that about that show and yet you see
hanayama koda who's 14 years old you're
like perfectly understandable have a
nice day because it makes it for some
reason like it checks out like i'm like
i don't know how it checks out i don't
doubt it right yeah because becky never
asks me once to like actually believe
this world is a real world yeah it just
completely is like listen bro this is
literally like the the equivalent of an
internet forum like debate where you're
like can goku beat saitama like that is
back you guys it never once asks you to
be invested in this world that's true
whereas like tokyo revenge for me felt
like it was trying to it was trying to
get me to get invested in the gangs and
the culture and stuff
but at the same time how are you gonna
make me believe that this is how 13 year
old and 14 odds react that they like
that they drive by motorcycles they do
all this [ __ ] and it's like they're
willing to like rob and kill each other
listen
if you made these kids 18 they can still
be in school yeah all of this would
still make sense and it's like just just
do that wow that's like that's like
basically 90 of anime where it's like
they don't need to be that age because
nobody actually their age actually acts
like them this is one where i actually
felt like it was to a massive detriment
that they were like super young and this
every single player just made it
unbelievable
not so unbelievable but like it made it
so to the fact that you're like it's
constantly asking you to just have this
level of disbelief right yeah to give it
like
okay i guess this is how 14 year olds
would react and respond to this
situation and it's like just just add on
four years they're still in school this
can work in college it all still works
the universe totally works it can work
when you're an adult as well yeah yeah
and now they can ride motorcycles no
question about it this is in japan yeah
no one is breaking the law engine
people don't even like they the only law
they break is stealing umbrellas that's
literally it that's all they do they
don't do that
no one is gonna how the [ __ ] are they
gonna get a motorcycle at 13 here i feel
like when i like the last time i felt
that like when when i felt like the
characters just weren't acting their age
at all uh was when i watched erased i
was gonna
erase was just like man these
five-year-olds how old were they like
five seconds
they're like nine year olds i feel like
you're like three yes using the forms of
relativity and quantum mechanics we can
actually predict when we were
like more capable than like like like
veteran detectives in the force and all
this [ __ ] and i'm just like bro these
are like nine-year-olds and they're
acting like grown adults that's why i
just couldn't get into a race this is
the exact same thing where i'm like this
nine-year-old like girl is like solving
mysteries that like [ __ ] 30-year
veterans [ __ ] crap
i know we've ranted about this before
and that we've we've you know we've
talked all about the asian stuff and i
do understand that like a lot of shows i
don't give a [ __ ] like it's totally fine
it's fiction it's whatever it doesn't
matter yeah but like again there are
some shows like erased where i feel like
doing this is just completely to the
detriment of the show and it makes you
sense suspend belief beyond reasonable
doubt yeah i don't know
there's a lot of one of the shows where
i'm like this is just stupid i mean like
there's also like your line in april as
well where a big thing that took me out
of the show is like i feel like they're
they went middle school or something
right i think they're 14 yeah 15. but
like everyone talks like a [ __ ] poet
you know everyone everything you know
the writing needs to match the eight
yeah yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] if you put him in
the school yeah you've got to write 13
year olds like 13 year olds so corsica
was talking like [ __ ] mozart was back
then you know and it's like dude you
should be you're 15. when i was 15 all i
was thinking about was poo poo pee pee
that's all i think about
way more sophisticated than you should
be for a few days yeah yeah yeah like
this this guy like came out of the womb
speaking in sonnets and all this [ __ ]
like he was studying shakespeare by the
age of three like michael's like my my
god like that that took me out so much
and uh
it was a small thing but it was just
like you could have easily made them
at a higher age to make them feel like
they were you know they had the ability
to speak like this but it was just they
were 14 years old and that was that was
the biggest thing that uh warriors just
it's annoying because sometimes just it
shows where like they write their
characters like 17 yards they act and
talk like 17 year olds they they behave
like 17 year olds why not just make them
[ __ ] 17. that's that's why i think to
this day the most perfect uh example of
like a perfectly age uh and you know
characters acting age appropriate in a
super realistic way was golden time
because it was like they were in college
and yet they were super immature like
most college students yeah yeah you know
like that's that's a realistic character
that's why i love golden yeah and that's
why that show was so good and it was so
immersive because it's like yeah i i
know people who are like this is such a
breath of fresh air i have saying
college yeah yeah yeah but they were
acting more like high school students
than most high school students were you
know in other shows
and it's like that's so [ __ ] ironic
yeah like that's what i feel like that's
why to me even now golden time is like
one of my favorite romances
just because it actually felt like these
were believable characters set in the
world that felt like it was based in
reality yeah not in this anime world
where 15 year olds 15 year olds are
doing quantum physics 14 year olds are
doing quantum physics um like [ __ ] i
mean you look at [ __ ] like naruto and
sasuke like they use hunter was another
one where i felt like they got the
characters ages like actually reflected
their personality you know yeah like don
was an idiot but like
like he he he would like be convinced to
do stuff by strangers like like like a
12 year old like a child like a 13 year
old unfortunately no no one over the age
of 18 is hanging out with his soccer you
know what i mean let's be honest for
good reason for good practice
oh he's talking to me okay
you know i mean like i appreciate it
when shows like actually treat the
characters like their age yeah like
because because like a lot of people
like for example naruto like a lot of
people forget that like in the og naruto
they're like he's like 10. they're 11
and 12 years old yeah and and like you
look at some of the [ __ ] they go through
like sasuke's like trying to revenge his
entire [ __ ] plan at the age of eleven
eleven he's he's
right
he's doing that right this man's
listening to too much my chemicals right
right get off that [ __ ]
i'll avenge my [ __ ] big mac if
someone slaps it out of my hand
so i believe that actually yeah i was a
very pa most realistic character
i don't know man i just i just kind of
wish that it would it would it would
change a little bit and you know and
that was one of the main reasons why i
was was a bit harsh on tokyo avengers
and that's why i got more annoyed
because it felt like it was just getting
stupid right now i mean i don't know if
i'm just like [ __ ] i've just seen so
adam so much anime that i'm just like
immune to this [ __ ] but just like it's
it's
it's it's very rare that a character's
age really comes into like any kind of
specific plot point or any bearing on
the plot itself because there's no like
it's so hard to tell a character's age
and anime based on just
their looks and their actions because
the range the range of anime characters
from like 13 to [ __ ] 28 yeah they
they all look the same and they all act
the same it's it's
like kind of like japanese people in
real life
maybe that's why maybe
right right they turn into adults yeah
like you look at it like you look at
like a japanese going you're like you
can be 12 or 30. did you see this one
i'm kind of afraid to ask you guys as
well for the tokyo uh revenges they had
to they made an uncensored version
um where because they used the sim the
temple symbol a lot
oh
unfortunately
uh he's you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh really
unfortunate and then they just that's a
sense of that they sent they made a
censored version where they just don't
use the symbol
yeah yeah it's weird in some ways i'm
like i mean i feel like they didn't need
to do that but i also kind of get it why
they wanted to be careful yeah i don't
know
it's yeah i mean i i can see why they
did that it's uh it's unfortunate but i
mean with how international anime is now
a lot of people could have taken it the
wrong way which was also
good moment to learn about another
culture and learn yeah right yeah yeah
you're like why are they using yeah
you'd be like what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
google is this okay
you know to me when that when i first
saw it i was like whoa and then you
google it you're like oh yeah oh okay
it's only been a symbol it's been around
for like i thought a lot longer yeah
it's just very unfortunate
naruto as well because i remember like
nedji's like clan symbol that he had on
his flight forehead or something was
originally based on that i believe
there's a lot of shows that i think use
those symbols and because it means like
like a pizza right
yeah it's yeah it's a buddhist right
it's very unfortunate it's a dichotomy
of uh
yeah
oh it's a cross okay
unless that's the censored version wait
wait is that the anime verb what is that
the anime version of the manga version
it was the enemy okay so the manga what
was the manga version of that
yeah
they made a whole version where they
they added it and then a whole nother
version where they just went through and
got rid of it yeah it's really hard
never mind all the vibes i feel like if
you're just gonna get rid of it just get
rid of it yeah yeah
i mean it's not gonna be a bit it's not
gonna be that big of a deal but he's the
uncensored one for you cultured
individuals out there cultures
actually
in a different religion
yeah yeah so like in the manga yeah it
was literally the monday yeah yeah yeah
that's what i thought that's what i
thought so yeah it was
yes i get it i if you want to avoid the
misunderstanding i get it
oh yeah yeah because on google maps they
use that symbol to mean uh
i have that on mine
i'm in english google maps oh really
yeah it's there yeah yeah
maybe in other other languages i swear
to god i'm on my on my google maps in
english i still see the the symbol oh
because like it was an issue like a
couple of years back because i was like
what is this
maybe if you're like not in japan yeah i
i feel like it's it's it's on the person
who comes to japan to educate themselves
kind of yeah because they and they're
the ones that are gonna throw a hissy
feet and look like an idiot yeah like i
understand it's a very unfortunate thing
obviously
with whom japan allied themselves with
yeah i can understand why the mistake
might be made
it's scary how 45 degrees changes
everything you know
right it's just a slight shift it just
completely changes over 45. angles
do you either want peace or you want
something that's definitely definitely
the opposite of peace
buddhism like uh i took a class from
this buddhism doesn't actually
distinguish between the orientation and
like which direction the swastika is
facing so technically all of them are
mean the same oh right right right but
yeah i mean most people wouldn't know
that though yeah yeah you know like
obviously when i saw it i didn't feel
like i was like oh my god what is this i
was just like oh what don't i know yeah
clearly i'm missing because i'd like to
be educated yeah yeah exactly i thought
exactly the same way i was just like
it's weird seeing that symbol but i'm
sure they would not be there's a good
reason i'm sure they wouldn't be putting
see if only everyone on the internet
thought you know what would have
rational thinking like that you know and
instead it was immediately like oh how
dare you we've said it a number of times
people aren't willing to give the
benefit the doubt people anymore that
that's that's gone out the window on the
internet and the year 2022 so
also they forget that different cultures
have different backgrounds and histories
that's what's strange is that people
really want to give benefit the doubt to
the country or even hide behind the
country's flaws
when it's convenient for them yeah but
when they don't understand something
they're like oh well you know i mean i
don't know i don't know they should have
explained it better
uh anyway keeping on anime i guess i
guess i guess since since i finally get
to talk about anime
uh i guess uh it's like i didn't
actually watch much anime this previous
season because i don't think there was
actually much good things oh god don't
say that everyone would get angry
there's no good enemy
yeah i did not learn my lesson
2021 well i think 2022 has been a pretty
weak year for anime so far but like i
guess like the only real recommendation
i i would have since you were going
through like last year uh is uh ranking
of kings that's literally the last one
i've been meaning to watch last night
last year
i mean it's continuing on to this year
so last last year was i mean it's a 23
episode show so last year we only had
like 12 episodes oh i mean i guess i'll
just wait then i'll yeah i'll all right
sweet source finished yeah
i mean it's almost finished but uh i
feel like it's only going to be a part
one of the story but yeah ranking of
kings is [ __ ] incredible i've heard
it's amazing yeah it's like un
un-ironically a lot of people like you
know maiden best didn't watch it because
it looked like a children's cartoon i
also didn't i didn't i also didn't watch
it because it looked like a children's
cartoon initially but
it's kind of like
a it's kind of like the closest thing to
like a ghibli movie i guess in terms of
like aesthetic
feelings
and i i really don't like ghibli movies
but it kind of gave me that kind of you
know you know when you're like watching
an anime fairy tale yeah it kind of
feels like that's like
i can only point to ghibli that gives
you that same kind of feeling but that's
the kind of feeling it's giving me um
but it also is written really really
[ __ ] well like it's been a while
since i've seen just an anime just this
well written and with characters this
interesting as well damn um it's like
it's like
to me like the spring season sorry the
winter season was like basically attack
on titan and demon slayer everyone was
like talking about yeah but like to me
ranking of kings is like close to that
level of quality in my opinion of just
like how good the show is well i mean
there's also my dress up darling as well
there's also my dress-up darling but
that like that
that occupies a different space in my
opinion you know that's a different
faction that's the definition that's a
different faction yeah
there's the attack on titan
core and then the [ __ ] microphone all
the way over here yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is like it was surprising to see
like in japan my ranking of kings is
really like shot up in popularity
i think it's like the most watched anime
right now it's because there's a lot of
voice actors who are saying
how good it is so like they're like
they're all like yeah this is really fun
there's a lot of power here yeah yeah
they do i mean top tier celebrities i
mean yeah they're just like they're not
even just voice actors here they're just
actors with uh celebrities they're just
like select gone to celebrity status as
well god damn and that's why they can
make questionable decisions like
hanazawa khan are selling nfts you know
which uh i saw that and i was like this
has to be a joke and then i watched the
video like please i was like please say
psycho connor please and then
i saw a lot of people that were like no
no i'm sure management i'm sure it's
just her management yeah i'm like yeah
but like but she agreed to it yeah
someone has to give the go ahead yeah
yeah like even if it is like her
management's idea or whatever she's yeah
she might have a manager but she's
allowed to say no yeah i love that it's
like you know no one ever uses that
excuse for western celebrities or
anything yeah it's always with the
japanese subjects like
also it's like i feel that only
implies to like you know kind of low
ranking uh talent right who maybe where
the management has a little more power
because it's like we're giving you the
big ones
literally top one percent of voice
actors yeah like she can she could say
no to whatever the [ __ ] she wants she
doesn't know what yeah she said yes to
the nfc she takes any role she wants you
know she can do any role she wants if
she says i want to be in this anime the
directors will be scrambling over
themselves to be like yes let's get
hanukkah in this
so
the whole management thing is just
[ __ ] yeah
she's literally
that is just hanakana fans in denial of
the fact that she's promoting it it's
just like her fans snorting pure copy
yeah it's it's it's just i've never seen
so much
i think there's never been like one of
my favorite uh memes is just like i
think it's like akuma image of just like
thing and it's like like a like a
depressed guy
japanese thing and it's just like
lighting up you know we've seen that
image yeah i love that
and it's just this is so true it's never
been a time when an image is more
pertinent than uh this the the other
version of that that i love is like uh
every instagram post it's like somewhere
and it's like really dark and it's like
somewhere in japan
i mean that's basically just the trash
taste podcast
[Music]
but no like i remember seeing that post
and i was just like oh why did it have
to be you why did it happen right it's
like if it was like some like dt or like
you know i voiced like one [ __ ]
passing by a person and selling in nfc i
would be like whatever the [ __ ] ever
you're literally one of the most notable
voice actors today i'm just like is this
how is this how idol fans felt when
their favorite idol gets through like a
controversy or they find out they have
like a boyfriend or something like i
think i get it now man like i'm just
like i felt betrayed you know
it's like why did it have to be you kind
of hung out
like i'm not i'm not even like mad i'm
just like disappointed yeah right i was
like i was disappointed i was like oh
come on man
i thought i thought we were better than
this yeah it was it was disappointing
but uh yeah i i haven't seen anyone
talking about it since i just saw it on
my timeline and i'm just like well that
sucks time there were a lot of even
japanese people on twitter just being
like no
no they're saying how did japanese
twitter react to it they're basically
the same as how western twitter was
really they were like dude why why you
it's like all the people brah moment
yeah that was a bra moment yeah well
that's that's been your weekly reminder
that nft suck yeah you know who else
doesn't conform to nft's uh our patrons
oh my god wonderful
you know they could use that money to
you know do all sorts of nft stuff but
thank god they don't
instead they're using it to support this
show the boys the boys their wallets out
for the boys thank you very much hey if
you'd like to pull the wallet out for
the boys and support the show then go to
our patreon patreon.com also follow us
on twitter send us a measure the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify but uh yeah yeah
that's been your yearly anime discussion
see you next year boys
all right see you next week bye
[Music]
you